l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet de loi constitutionnel relatif à
la liberté de recourir à l'interruption
volontaire de
grossesse la parole est à monsieur Éric
Dupont Moretti garde d' saau ministre de
la
[Applaudissements]
Justice
h madame la
présidente madame la ministre cher
Aurore monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur si vous
voulez cher Sacha si ça vous fait
plaisir mesdames messieurs les
députés les filles comme
moi gâchaient la journée des médecin
elle les obligeait à se rappeler la loi
qui pouvait les envoyer en prison et
leur interdire d'exercer pour
toujours il n'osaient pas dire la vérité
qu' n'allait pas risquer de tout perdre
pour les beaux yeux d'une demoiselle
assez
stupide pour se faire mettre en
cloque c'est par ces
mots que la narratrice du roman
l'événement d'ny
hernaud se remémore les circonstances de
son avortement clandestin en janvier
1964 c'est
mots pourrait être ceux de nos mères de
nos sœurs de nos grand-mères de nos
tantes de nos amis ces mots pourrai être
ceux de toutes les femmes qui ont vécu
dans leur chair l'interdiction de
l'avortement ce sentiment de ne pas
pouvoir disposer de son corps d'être à
la merci d'une grossesse qu'elle ne
pas ces mots Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés et la souffrance qu'il
définissent nous oblige il nous rappelle
un fait très
simple il n'y a pas de démocratie digne
de ce nom lorsque la moitié de sa
population ne peut
s'émanciper
non une démocratie ne peut pas maîtriser
son destin
si les femmes qui y vivent n'ont pas la
liberté de maîtriser le
leur voilà pourquoi la liberté de
recourir à l'IVG n'est pas une liberté
comme les autres car elle permett aux
femmes de décider de leur avenir
l'histoire
regorge d'exemples de
liberté de droits fondamentaux conquis
au prix du sang et des larmes que tous
je dis bien tous croyaient
définitivement acquis et qui dans la
stupeur ou l'indifférence ont été balayé
d'un revers de manche c'est d'ailleurs
l'histoire de la femme qui nous en offre
les plus cruels exemples car oui les
premiers droits qui disparaissent sont
souvent ceux des
femmes c'est ce que nous a rappelé
récemment la décision de la Cour suprême
des
États-Unis cet exemple rend plus que
jamais criant criant de vérité les mots
de Simone de beauauvoir rapportés par
Claudine Monteille n'oubliez jamais
qu'il vous suffira d'une crise
politique économique
ou
religieuse pour que les droits des
femmes soient remis en question ces
droits ne sont jamais acquis vous devrez
rester vigilant votre vie
durant nous avons désormais la preuve
irréfutable que plus aucune démocratie
pas même la plus grande d'entre toutes
n'est à
l'abri mesdames et messieurs les députés
je suis
particulièrement fier d'être parmi vous
aujourd'hui pour porter
le projet de loi
constitutionnelle relatif à la liberté
de recourir à l'interruption volontaire
de
grossesse si je parle d'un projet de
loin c'est bien parce que c'est le
gouvernement qui présente ce texte mais
mais je dois à la vérité de dire qu'il
s'agit plutôt d'une forme de 3è lecture
tant les initiatives parlementaires ont
été nombreuses est le sujet débattu au
Parlement ces derniers mois je veux ici
rendre solennellement hommage à
l'ensemble des initiatives
parlementaires de l'ancienne présidente
berger ma chère AORE à la présidente
Panau en passant par la sénatrice Vogel
ou encore le sénateur Philippe
B le projet que je vous présente fait
suite à ces travaux et à la volonté du
Président de la République d'inscrire
cette liberté dans le marbre de notre
Constitution le 8 mars dernier à
l'occasion de son discours prononcé en
hommage à Giselle Alimi le président de
la République a émis le souhait je le
cite de changer notre Constitution afin
d'y graver la liberté des femmes à
recourir à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse pour assurer solennellement
que rien ne pourra entraver ou défaire
ce qui sera ainsi
irréversible c'est donc ce que nous nous
apprêtons à faire cet après-midi à
l'Assemblée
national comme le Conseil d'État l'a
souligné dans son avis d'une très grande
qualité il n'existe pas
aujourd'hui de véritable protection
supra législative
du droit ou de la liberté de recourir à
l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse la Convention européenne des
droits de l'homme ne comporte pas de
dispositions spécifiqu sur
l'avortement par ailleurs la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme
considère que le droit au respect de la
vie privée et familiale protégé par
l'article 8 de la Convention ne consacre
pas un droit à l'avorte
de la même manière la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne se borne à rappeler
en l'absence de dispositions spécifiques
sur ce point la compétence des
États-membres et renvoie à
l'appréciation du législateur
national quant au Conseil
constitutionnel il a jugé conforme à la
Constitution les différentes lois
relatives à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse mais ce faisant il a examiné
l'équilibre ménagé entre d'une part la
sauvegarde de la dignité de la personne
humaine contre toute forme de
dégradation et d'autre part la liberté
de la femme qui découle de l'article 2
de la Déclaration de
1789 il n'est pas aller plus loin il a
même pris le soin de souligner au sujet
de uption volontaire de grossesse qu'il
ne dispose pas d'un pouvoir général
d'appréciation et de décision de même
nature que celui du Parlement et qu'il
ne lui appartient donc pas de remettre
en cause au regard de l'état des
connaissances et des techniques les
dispositions prises par le
législateur
ainsi la liberté des femmes de recourir
à l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
ne bénéficie pas à ce jour de
véritable consécration
constitutionnel alors que Simon ve
s'exprimait le 26 novembre
1964 devant l'Assemblée nationale pour
porter sa grande loi elle inscrivait son
projet sous le signe de
l'espérance permettez-moi
humblement de reprendre ici ses mots
alors qu'elle concluait son discours
pour convaincre les députés encore
hésitants
mesdames messieurs les députés je ne
suis pas de ceux de celles qui redoute
l'avenir Simon veille croyait
profondément que la loi qu'elle portait
alors permettrait à la Société française
de progresser et l'avenir lui lui a bien
heureusement donné raison mais car il y
a un ma mesdames et messieurs les
députés j'aimerais tant vous dire à
cette
tribune presque 50 ans après la
légalisation de l'avortement que non moi
non plus je ne redoute pas l'avenir
j'aimerais tant pouvoir vous dire que je
ne suis pas de ceux qui s'inquiètent
face à l'avenir et aux incertitudes
qu'il Chari parfois j'aimerais tant être
de ceux qui tranquille et d'un pas
assuré avancecent unouciant sur le
chemin de la vie croyant que ce qui est
acquis est acquis pour toujours
j'aimerais tant enfin être de ceux qui
d'un revers de main balayent les
exemples étrangers où le droit recule et
avec lui souvent la condition des femmes
comme aux États-Unis en Hongrie
ou en Pologne où les femmes sont forcées
d'écouter les battements de cœur du
fetus avant
d'avorter qui peut aujourd'hui garantir
que ceux qui ses produits
outreAtlantique ne pourrai pas se
produire en France oh bien s pas demain
mais à plus long terme le pire n'est
jamais certain le meilleur non plus et
c'est à raison de cette
incertitude que je suis favorable à ce
que l'on élève la grande loi Veil celle
de
1975 telle qu'aujourd'hui modifié au
sommet de notre hiérarchie des normes à
ceux qui répondent que l'IVG n'est pas
menacé en France je dis que l'on n'écrit
pas la Constitution seulement pour le
présent mais d'abord et surtout pour
l'avenir c'est le propre même de la loi
suprême de durée de valoir pour l'avenir
en protégeant nos droits les acquis
démocratiques et notre État de
droit l'objectif du gouvernement vous
l'avez compris est clair
et il rejoint je crois les positions
déjà exprimées par l'Assemblée nationale
et le Sénat l'objectif de ce projet de
loi constitutionnel est d'accorder à
cette liberté une véritable protection
constitutionnelle cette protection
constitutionnelle doit être suffisamment
souple pour permettre au législateur de
continuer son œuvre en la matière et
donc ménager un équilibre satisfaisant
au regard notamment des évolutions
techniques médicales ou scientifiques
qui pourrait advenir ce qu'il s'agit
d'empêcher mesdames et messieurs c'est
que le législateur puisse un jour
interdire tout recours à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse ou même qu'il en
restreigne si drastiquement les
conditions d'accès que la substance même
de la liberté courir s'en trouverait
alors irréédiablement
atteinte
voilà notre
objectif c'est cet équilibre entre les
versions votées au Sénat et à
l'assemblée que le gouvernement s'est
attelé à trouver la réaction proposé
aujourd'hui permet de répondre aux
attentes mais aussi aux craintes d'une
grande grande partie de nos
parlementaires le gouvernement souhaite
consacrer pleinement la valeur
constitutionnelle de la liberté de la
femme de recourir à l'IVG tout en
reconnaissant le rôle du législateur
d'organiser les condition d'exercice de
cette
liberté en effet le projet de loi
comporte une disposition unique ayant
pour objet de modifier l'article 34 de
la Constitution en ajoutant après le 17e
alinéa un alinéa ainsi
rédigé la loi détermine les conditions
dans lesquelles s'exerce la liberté
garantie à la femme d'avoir recours à
une interruption volontaire de grossesse
le
[Musique]
gouvernement madame si je peux madame
prononcer mon discours sans que vous
m'interrompiez en permanence je vous en
ser extrêmement
reconnaissantz
insupportable s'il vous plaît monsieur
le ministre le gouvernement a donc tout
d'abord retenu l'article 34 de la
Constitution comme l'avait fait le Sénat
en terme juridique cet emplacement
paraître en effet le plus
adapté il faut à ce titre rappeler que
la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel reconnaît que l'article
34 de la Constitution peut contrairement
à ce qu'une première lecture pourrait
sembler indiquer accueillir les règles
de fond et mettre des obligations
positives à la charge de législateur
c'est par exemple ce qui a été fait avec
la révision constitutionnelle
du 23 juillet 2008 qui a prévu à
l'article 34 que la loi fixe les règles
concernant notamment la liberté le
pluralisme et l'indépendance des médias
le projet fait par ailleurs le choix du
mot liberté plutôt que du mot droit ce
choix très
commenté ne doit pas être surestimé car
ainsi que l'a relevé dans son avis le
Conseil d'État il n'existe pas en droit
positif ni dans la jurisprudence du
Conseil constitutionnel de différence
établies entre les deux termes si le
gouvernement a choisi ce terme c'est
dans un souci de clarté il ne s'agit pas
en effet de créer un droit absolu sans
limite mais de faire référence
à l'autonomie de la femme et de garantir
dans l'exercice d'une liberté qui lui
appartient dans les conditions prévues
par la loi
enfin pourrait intervenir tout à l'heure
on a rallongé on a doublé le temps de
discussion générale justement pour
permettre au groupe d'exprimer chacun
dans sa diversité son opinion je
remercie de laisser le ministre
s'exprimer vous aurez de fois plus de
temps pour critiquer le texte le moment
venu mais laissez-moi terminer s'il vous
plaît enfin le Gouvernement a souhaité
par la rédaction qu'il propose insister
sur le fait que si les conditions de
cette liberté sont déterminées par le
législateur cette liberté doit rester
dans tous les cas garantie aux femmes
qui en bénéficient c'est là un point
particulièrement
important ce mot garanti issu des
travaux menés par votre assemblée vise
là aussi à exprimer clairement
l'intention
poursuivi que les choses soient bien
claires il ne s'agit pas d'une simple
attribution de compétenence au
législateur mais bien de la création
d'une obligation positive à sa charge
celle de protéger cette liberté que la
Constitution anti dans les conditions
qu'il estime approprié l'objectif est
bien qu'aucune majorité future ne puisse
réellement porter atteinte à cette
liberté intangible qui est celle pour la
femme de disposer de son
corps un mot
enfin sur les effets attendu de cette
révision
constitutionnelle tout d'abord c'est un
point important aucune disposition
législative en vigueur ne devrait voir
remise en cause par l'adoption de cette
révision de la
Constitution le Conseil d'État l'a
lui-même très
précisément constater et tel est bien
l'intention du gouvernement de manière
claire et précise et pour répondre par
anticipation à certaines craintes
exprimées ici ou là je pense notamment à
Madame la Députée Bonivard qui pose des
questions légitime la consécration de
cette liberté n'emporte pas la remise en
question n'emporte la remise en question
d'aucune autre liberté et notamment pas
la liberté de conscience des médecins
des chasses des sages femmes qui leur
permet de choisir de ne pas pratiquer
d'IVG si c est contraire à leur
conviction cette liberté là je l'affirme
est totalement préservé autre point
important le principe de respect de la
dignité de la personne humaine est lui
aussi préservé une loi qui porterait par
exemple le délai maximal pour avorter à
30 semaines pourrait donc être tout à
fait censuré y compris par la présente
révision ensuite la tion proposé entend
bien rendre clairire le fait que la
décision d'avorter n'appartient qu'à la
femme enceinte et a elle seule elle ne
nécessite ni autorisation d'un tiers que
ce soit les conjoints les parents
l'appréciation d'une autre personne ne
peut pas intervenir cette liberté est
strictement personnel
elle est d'ailleurs reconnue à toutes
les femmes enceintes et même à toute
personn enceinte sans considération de
son état civil sans considération de son
âge de sa nationalité ou de la
régularité de son séjour en France enfin
j'y insiste cette rédaction ne vise pas
à créer une forme de droit opposable
absolu et sans limite le gouvernement
n'ignore pas les difficultés matérielles
et concrètes qui peuvent encore exister
dans l'accès à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse et notamment sur certaines
parties du
territoire mais il s'agit là mesdames et
messieurs les députés d'un autre sujet
qui n'est pas d'ordre constitutionnel en
effet nous nous retrouvons aujourd'hui
pour réviser notre Constitution et non
pas pour voter je ne sais quelle mesure
relevant du périmètre du ministère de la
Santé qui est pleinement mobilisé pour
améliorer l'accès à l'IVG partout en
France cette révision de la Constitution
ne lèvera pas toutes les difficultés
mais elle protégera les femmes en France
d'une éventuelle régression brutale de
leur liberté de recourir à l'avortement
c'est là la volonté exprimée par
l'Assemblée puis par le Sénat et c'est
là le objectif du président de la
République objectif poursuivi par le
gouvernement je ve prendre un instant
pour
remercier chaleureusement le rapporteur
Gouffier Valente militant que je
qualifie d'éclairer militant infatigable
du droit des femmes et partenaire hors
pa dans le projet qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui je sais que sa pédagogie a
convaincu en commission comme en
témoigne l'adoption du texte nos débats
en séance poursuivront dans cette voie
du dialogue du consensus et du respect
un dernier mot enfin pour répondre à un
certain nombre de
critiques ça a été
fait bon écoutez vous aurez à nouveau 10
minutes pour vous exprimer au nom de
votre groupe et vous pourrez remercier
qui vous souhaitez monsieur le ministre
un dernier mot enfin pour répondre à un
certain nombre de critiques et de
craintes et de craintes qui se sont
exprimées depuis que je suis à la
Chancellerie j'ai toujours respecté les
convictions de chacun sur les sujets
sociétaux aussi j'entends et je respecte
les craintes sur ce que certains
perçoivent comme la création d'un droit
absolu et sans limite mais je veux les
rassurer il n'en est rien il s'agit
aujourd'hui de donner une protection
constitutionnelle à à l'état actuel de
notre droit j'ai entendu la crainte du
président Larcher que la Constitution ne
devienne je le cite un catalogue de
droits sociaux et
sociétaux là encore je partage ch
crainte oui la Constitution doit
demeurer ce qu'elle est à savoir
notamment le recueil de nos libertés
fondamentales je crois donc que la
liberté de recourir à l'IVG il a toute
sa place je veux enfin revenir sur les
questions de calendrier
parlementaire je sais les mois qui a pu
provoquer la pseudoannonce d'une date de
congrès avant même que les chambres se
soient
prononcées je veux dissiper tout
malentendu ça a été perçu par
certains comme un manque de respect à
l'encontre du Parlement permettez-moi de
revenir à la parole présidentielle
initiale lors des rencontre de
Saint-Denis le président de la
République n'a jamais parlé que d'une
possibilité de congrès voilà les termes
précis de ce qu'il proposait aux
différents partis politiques j'ouvre les
guillemets un examen dans chaque
assemblée pourra avoir lieu au prer
trimestre
2024 afin qu'un congrès puisse être
envisagé le 4 mars prochain vous le
voyez il ne s'agit bien là que d'une
possibilité c'est pourquoi je veux vous
rassurer nous prendrons le temps qu'il
faut pour aller au bout de cette
révision car je crois profondément que
nous pouvons y arriver car tout
j'insiste tout dans le projet de loi qui
vous est présenté et fait pour que
chacun puisse voter sans crainte cette
écriture calibrée et souspesé ce projet
de révision de la Constitution mesdames
et messieurs les députés constitue le
point d'équilibre entre les nombreux
travaux engagés dans les deux chambres
et commencés ici même parce qu'elle
respecte les priorités de l'Assemblée
parce qu'elle respecte le travail du
Sénat c'est cette rédaction doit nous
permettre de trouver une majorité dans
les deux chambres et ensuite d'obtenir
une majorité qualifiée au Congrès nos
débats doivent permettre de dissiper les
dernières hésitation afin que notre pays
par le vote de cette loi
constitutionnelle franchisse un pas
historique pour les femmes de notre pays
la France deviend alors le premier pays
au monde à protéger cette liberté
inaliénable de la femme dans sa
constitution mais avant cela il faut que
l'Assemblée adopte ce texte et ce de la
manière la plus large possible les
Français et peut-être surtout les
Françaises nous regarde si nous
réussissons dans ce
travail doutons pas ce sera le monde
entier qui tournera son regard vers
notre pays la France aura alors été une
fois de plus au rendez-vous de sa
vocation
universelle merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Aurore
berger ministre déléguée chargée de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et de la lutte contre les
[Applaudissements]
discriminations merci madame la
présidente monsieur le garde des saau
cher Éric Dupont Moretti monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
présidente de la délégation au droits
des f femme mesdames et messieurs les
députés l'histoire de l'avortement c'est
d'abord l'histoire du corps des femmes
qui est et a toujours été un corps
politique un corps scruté réglé
rangé un corps qui examine la loi sous
toutes les coutures à qui l'on a cessé
de prescrire prescrire des façons d'être
de se tenir de se vêtir un corps dont
des hommes réunis en assemblée ont
déterminé les règles selon lesquelles il
avait le droit de recourir ou non à la
contraception de vivre ou de ne pas
vivre sa grossesse d'entrer dans la
maternité quand la loi s'est-elle
penchée de cette façon sur le corps des
hommes quand s'est-elle interrogée sur
leur sexe est-elle entrée dans leur
ventre a-t-elle scruté jusqu'au fond de
leurs entrailles l'histoire de
l'avortement c'est l'histoire de celle
qui ne se range pas parce qu'elles ne le
veulent pas parce qu'elles ne le peuvent
pas des femmes à qui on réserve tous les
raffinements de la douleur et de la
honte car il n'a jamais suffit
d'interdire aux femmes encore fallait-il
les faire souffrir l'histoire de
l'avortement c'est un cintre plongé dans
un utérus sur une table de cuisine ce
sont des Vissers des intestin perforé
des femmes mourant de septicémie comme
il en meurt encore aujourd'hui 40000 à
travers le monde à la suite d'un
avortement réalisé dans des conditions
indignes ce sont des curtages pratiqués
sans anesthésie dans les hôpitaux parce
que ça lui apprendra ce sont ces gamines
violées qu'on enfermait dans les
couvents de la Madeleine pour leur
apprendre à aguicher les hommes c'est
cette mère de famille épuisée qu'on
embarquait au poste parce qu'elle
n'avait pas voulu d'un nouvel enfant
dans cette histoire des femmes ont lutté
et des hommes auprès d'elles de grandes
héroïnes Simone veille GIS la liimi
Lucien nevirt Eugène Claudius petit
Jacques Chirac des médecins des avocats
et des foules d'anonyme de femmes qui se
recommandaient une adresse dans le coin
d'une cuisine qui se formaient comme
elle pouvait aux méthodes d'aspiration
qui s'entouraient qui
s'entraidaient parmi elles les plus
exposées n'ont peut-être pas été celles
à qui nous avons justement rendu hommage
parce que la lutte pour l'avortement
était aussi une lutte de classe qui
a-t-on condamné dans les procès de
l'avortement les caissières les
ouvrières les employés celles qui trime
qui écume et qui galère celle à qui
s'impose toujours en premier les
servitudes que l'on réserve aux femmes
et aujourd'hui aujourd'hui quel soin
avons-nous d'elle sommes-nous à la
hauteur de ce qui pèse sur leur vie et
ce qui pèse sur leur corps quand nous
avons il y a maintenant plus d'un an
déposé une proposition de loi visant à
inscrire la liberté des femmes à
recourir à l'avortement dans le texte
fondamental et fondateur de notre
République tant de voix se sont élevé
pour nous dire que c'était inutile ou
superflu qu'il s'agissait d'une
diversion politique pour détourner le
regard de sujets sérieux que c'était un
symbole pour bourgeoise en mal de combat
et bien oui oui cette loi est un symbole
un symbole fier de ce que nous sommes de
ce en quoi nous croyons et de ce qui
fondent le projet d'émancipation et
d'égalité de notre pays mais cette loi
n'est pas seulement un symbole parce que
pour des femmes trop nombreuses encore
ce droit est entravé par des défauts
d'accès à l'information d'accès aux
soins d'accès à un accompagnement adapté
parce qu'incidieusement à travers le
monde ce droit recule parce que quand
des sociétés qui apparaissaient comme
des terres de liberté les fractures et
le repli conduisent à s'attaquer à ce
qui nous semblait définitivement acquis
il n'est pas de raison de croire que ce
qui arrive autour de nous ne pourra pas
arriver chez nous comme si nous étions
préservés ici de toute régression et si
l'on abattait ce symbole si ce qui a
incarné au plus haut point la lutte
d'émancipation des femmes en venait à
tomber alors tout le reste
cèderait je fais partie d'une génération
qui croyait que l'histoire avancerait
inéluctablement vers le progrès des
sociétés que les combats se gagneraient
pied à pied et sans retour l'avortement
était acquis avec lui la libération
sexuelle l'égalité des droits puis
viendrait l'égalité des salaires
l'égalité réelle un monde où il ne
serait plus question d'être une femme ou
d'être un homme mais d'être soi libérer
des déterminismes des assignations des
conditionnement des rôles imposés ou de
la violence il suffisait que d'autres
générations prennent la place et
l'affaire serait réglée mesdames et
messieurs les députés j'aurais voulu
qu'il n'y ait plus besoin de ministre de
l'Égalité j'aurais voulu que ce combat
s'arrête par la disparition même de son
objet déposer les armes savoir que par
l'intelligence collective nous étions
parvenus à nous défaire de ces
enfermements et de cette violence
j'aurais voulu que cette entrée de
livéger dans la Constitution soit une
cérémonie domhommage un point final le
clairon que l'on sonne après la victoire
votons votons réjouissons-nous et
finissons-en mais ce temps n'est pas
encore venu l'histoire résiste et c'est
pourquoi nous sommes ici aujourd'hui
conscient du caractère fondateur de ce
débat et de ce vote vous apprêtez je moi
je l'espère a voté pour inscrire
l'avortement dans la Constitution à la
faveur d'un projet porté par le
Président de la République et le garde
des sauts soutenu par lui dès le premier
jour soutenu par des parlementaires sur
tous ses bancs à l'Assemblée nationale
comme au Sénat cela aurait été
inimaginable il y a 50 ans une femme
parle aujourd'hui à une assemblée
composée indistinctement de femmes et
d'hommes et présidé par une femme cela
aurait été inimaginable il y a 50 ans
mais nous savons aussi désormais qu'il
ne suffit pas d'un changement de
génération pour acter la victoire des
droits des femmes ce texte n'est donc
pas un point final il est un moment un
moment que prend la République pour
mettre en sécurité une liberté précieuse
avant de reprendre la marche mesdames et
messieurs les députés ce vote sera l'un
des plus importants un des plus
marquants de cette
législature je suis la fille d'une mère
qui a risqué la prison et la mort pour
avorter dans la clandestinité et la mère
d'une fille que je souhaite voir grandir
libre libre de disposer de son corps
d'un corps qui ne soit plus scruté plus
réglé plus rangé mesdames et messieurs
les députés dans ce débat et par vos
votes soyons tout simplement à la
hauteur à la hauteur de nos mères et à
la hauteur de nos filles je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre
la parole est à présent à monsieur
Guillaume Gouffier Vallante rapporteur
de la commission des lois
constitutionnelles de la législation et
de l'administration générale de la
République
merciadame la
présid madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
madame la présidente de la délégation au
droits des femmes mes chers collègues
certains textes sont particulièrement
attendus celui qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui relatif à la liberté de
recourir à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse en fait partie à moins d'un an
du 50e anniversaire de la loi veille et
dans la suite des initiatives
parlementaires qui avaient été prises au
début de cette législature et je tiens à
saluer les travaux et engagements de nos
collègues notamment baptistel panneau
fossillon Vogel balanan rixin et de
notre ancienne collègue Aurore berger je
salue le choix du président de la
République de remettre l'ouvrage sur le
métier pour aboutir à une adoption
rapide et autonome de cette révision qui
doit nous permettre d'introduire dans
notre Constitution la reconnaissance de
la liberté de recourir à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse et d'en assurer
la protection la plus forte possible le
Parlement a travaillé en bonne
intelligence et nous nous devons de
poursuivre sur cette voie pour mémoire
en novembre 2022 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté une rédaction fruit d'un
consensus transpartisan qui
reconnaissait la garantie du droit à
l'IVG et un accès effectif à à celui-ci
dans la foulée le Sénat qui avait
jusqu'àors fait valoir sa réticence à
l'inscription de l'IVG dans la
Constitution a également adopté une
rédaction certes moins ambitieuse mais
dont le sens était néanmoins clair
historique par ces deux votes les deux
chambres ont signalé qu'elle souhaitait
faire aboutir une révision
constitutionnelle sur ce sujet que les
choses soient claires ici si nous
combattons ceux qui s'attaque au droit à
l'avortement et au droits des femmes
nous respectons l'opinion de ceux qui
s'interrogent sur l'opportunité
d'inscrire le droit ivg dans la
Constitution nous le savons réformer
notre Constitution est un acte fort
exigeant il est la volonté que nous
exprimons nous constituant d'inscrire le
choix du peuple présent pour le peuple
futur réformer notre Constitution c'est
au fond marquer le présent pour protéger
l'avenir en outre pour le bon déroulé de
nos débats je crois qu'il faut aussi
circonscrire le périmètre de nos
discussions je veux dire clairement en
préambule de nos discussions ce que ce
projet est et ce qu'il n'est pas il ne
s'agit pas aujour aujourd'hui de
discuter du cadre législatif en vigueur
ni de préparer de futures évolutions
législatives visant à élargir la liberté
de recourir à l'IVG il ne s'agit pas non
plus de créer un droit opposable nos
débats seront scrutés en cas de
contentieux et les intentions du
Gouvernement et du Parlement doivent
être clair la rédaction soumise
n'implique nullement une évolution du
droit existant et ne saurait être source
d'un nouveau contentieux par exemple par
voie de question prioritair de
constitutionnalité le Conseil d'État est
on peu plus clair sur ce point dans son
avis en revanche le projet qui nous est
soumis remplit l'objectif que nous
partageons faire en sorte qu'il ne soit
pas possible de modifier la loi afin
d'interdire tout recours à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
ou d'en restreindre les conditions
d'exercice de telle façon qu'elle
priverait cette liberté de toute portée
l'adoption de ce texte nous paraît
indispensable pour assurer la
reconnaissance réelle de cette liberté
et renforcer la protection juridique la
Constitution recense déjà de nombreux
droits et libertés sans distinguer
d'ailleurs ces deux notions qui valent
l'une pour l'autre dans ces préambules
mais également dans ces articles laïcité
égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
interdiction de la peine de mort libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales droit d'asile et bien
d'autres il n'y a donc pas d'incohérence
ou de risque à reconnaître un nouveau
droit au contraire il est même de la
responsabilité du législateur
constituant d'en prendre la
responsabilité sans attendre que le
Conseil constitutionnel reconnaisse ou
non ce nouveau droit de manière
prétorienne ne croyons pas non plus que
la protection de l'IVG par la loi est
suffisante pour nous prémunir contre
tout risque d'atteinte à cette liberté
certes le Conseil constitutionnel a
admis la conformité à la Constitution
des différentes réformes concernant
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
il a considéré que le législateur avait
toujours respecté l'équilibre entre la
liberté de la femme tel qu'elle découle
de l'article 2 de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen et la
sauvegarde de la dignité de la personne
humaine contre toute forme de
dégradation notons cependant trois
limites à cette protection premièrement
s'il admet sa constitutionnalité le
Conseil n'a jamais reconnu
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
comme un droit ou une liberté
fondamentale en soi comme il a pu le
faire dans d'autres cas la liberté
d'enseignement par exemple deuxièmement
le Conseil n'a jamais eu à se prononcer
sur une restriction du droit à l'IVG et
on peut s'interroger sur sa capacité à
déclarer inconstitutionnelle de tes
dispositions sur le fondement de
l'équilibre qu'il a défini qui repose
sur une interprétation déjà extensive de
l'article 2 de la Déclaration des Droits
de l'Homme et du Citoyen troisièmement
le Conseil reconnaît sur cette question
un large pouvoir d'appréciation au
législateur ce qui est bien normal
contenu du silence des textes
constitutionnels en la
matière c'est cette ambiguïé mes chers
collègues et cette incertitude que nous
souhaitons lever sans priver le juge
constitutionnel de son office la
modification de l'article 34 envoie
explicitement à la prérogative du
législateur pour encadrer cette liberté
qui ne saurait être absolu l'ajout du
mot garantie principale évolution par
rapport à la rédaction du Sénat qui est
très largement reprise par ailleurs doit
renforcer la protection désormais de
rang constitutionnel de cette liberté
contre d'éventuelles atteintes à
l'avenir à l'inverse je vous le dis la
suppression du mot garanti rétablirait
une incertitude sur l'intention du
constituant voire même indiquerait que
celui-ci à contrario n'a pas souhaité
garantir ce droit ce qui serait
contreproductif c'est pourquoi nous
resterons impérativement attachés à ce
mot plus largement concernant l'ensemble
de la rédaction qui nous est proposée
par le projet de loi constitutionnel je
vous le dis chers collègues je pense
qu'elle est la plus robuste et la plus
opportune sur le plan juridique au
regard des auditions que j'ai mené de la
vie du Conseil d'État vie
particulièrement positif concernant la
rédaction qui est proposée des travaux
de nos collègues sénateurs des
discussions que nous avons eu en
commission des lois mercredi dernier je
défends la position aujourd'hui que
cette rédaction est précise et ne crée
aucune ambivalence concernant l'objectif
que nous poursuivons l'emplacement
retenu à l'article 34 de la Constitution
fait sens au regard de notre histoire
constitutionnelle et de son évolution il
n'a aucunement pour conséquence de
donner moins de portée à la liberté
ainsi garantie cette rédaction est enfin
de nature à garantir une protection qui
respecte le choix individuel de chaque
personne qui souhaite recourir à une
interruption volontaire de grossesse je
pense par ailleurs que cette rédaction
est de nature à nous permettre de
trouver un accord avec nos collègues
sénateurs car elle repart des travaux de
qualité qu'ils ont mené sur le sujet au
début de l'année 2023 et qui ont ouvert
le chemin vers la présentation de ce
projet de loi constitutionnelle c'est la
raison pour laquelle comme lors de la
commission des lois je n'ai pas déposé
le moindre amendement et que je vous
inviterai à retenir la rédaction qui
nous est proposée cette rédaction a
d'ailleurs été largement adoptée par la
par les commissaires aux lois sans
modification le 17 janvier dernier je
note également que lors de nos débat en
commission la majorité des députés a
exprimé son attachement à travailler à
la construction d'un accord avec le
Sénat sur ce projet de révision
constitutionnelle et j'en veux pour
preuve le débat que nous avons eu sur
les amendements de rétablissement des
écritures initiales des différentes
proposition de loi qui nous ont permis
d'avoir un débat juridique je pense
abouti avant qu'il ne soit retiré au
profit de la rédaction initiale du
présent projet de loi constitutionnelle
bien entendu les débats que nous aurons
lors de cette séance sur les amendements
qui ont été déposés demeureront
particulièrement important comme lors de
la commission ils nous permettront de
mettre en lumière l'objectif poursuivi
et les choix juridiques qui ont conduit
à cette rédaction et je salue le fait
qu'à l'exception de quelques amendements
l'ensemble des amendements déposés a un
rapport avec le projet de révision de la
Constitution qui nous est proposée mes
chers collègues cette révision
intervient dans un contexte qui inquiète
celles et ceux qui défendent les droits
des femmes rappelons qu'en Europe et aux
États-Unis ce droit est menacé l'arrêt
de la Cour suprême américaine véritable
électrochoc nous a rappelé que même dans
un pays aussi développé et attaché aux
libertés que les États-Unis un recul du
droit à l'IVG est possible je ne pose
pas leur situation juridique à notre
pays mais force de constater que ce
droit comme disait Simone de beauoir
n'est jamais acquis et qu'il peut suffir
d'une crise pour que les droits des
femmes soient remis en cause en Pologne
en Hongrie les gouvernements ont mis en
place de nouvelles barrières à l'accès à
l'IVG comme l'obligation d'écouter le
cœur du bébé ou l'interdiction d'avorter
en cas de malformation du fitus le droit
européen ne nous apporte d'ailleurs
aucune garantie en la matière qu'à la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme et
la Cour de justice de l'Union européenne
laisse une grande marge d'appréciation
aux états la matière les militants dit
antichois sont très actifs en France et
reçoivent d'importants financements les
entraves prennent des formes de plus en
plus pernicieuses certaines plateformes
vont jusqu'à proposer des numéros verts
pour se faire passer pour des organismes
publics et dissuader ensuite les femmes
qui les appellent les les attaques à
l'encontre du droit à l'avortement
nourrissent le débat public à l'image de
certains amendements d'ailleurs que nous
aurons à discuter aujourd'hui ne croyons
donc pas que la France est complètement
imperméable à ce risque et c'est juste
justement parce que ce droit est encore
solidement ancré en France qu'il faut
aujourd'hui le protéger je le redis à
cette tribune on ne prend pas une
assurance quand la maison brûle par
cette révision la France enverrait enfin
un message fort dans le monde entier en
en devenant le premier pays à
reconnaître l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse dans le texte de sa
constitution qui a servi de modèle à
tant de pays à travers l'histoire en
somme pour conclure ce texte d'une
certaine manière c'est rien et tout à la
fois
il n'est rien parce qu'il ne vient pas
bouleverser le droit
existant mais ce texte il est tout parce
qu'il crée un bouclier pour le futur en
érigeant la liberté de recourir à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et c'est-à-dire à la liberté de disposer
de son corps parmi les libertés
fondamentales devant être garanti par un
État de droit au 21e siècle une
reconnaissance qui je le pense vient
renforcer notre démocratie je vous
remerci je vous remercie monsieur le
[Musique]
rapporteur la parole est à Monsieur
Sacha AER président de la commission des
lois de la législation et de
l'administration générale de la
[Applaudissements]
République madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Gard des saau madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
messieurs les députés chers collègues
c'est un jour important pour notre
assemblée nous examinons aujourd'hui le
projet de loi constitutionnel relatif à
la liberté de courir à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse si notre
assemblée vote ce texte si le Sénat
l'approuve dans les mêmes termes si le
Parlement réunion en congrès l'adopte
alors la liberté de recourir à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
sera inscrite dans nos constitution la
France deviendra le premier pays du
monde à la garantie si notre assemblée
vote ce texte si le Sénat l'adopte dans
les mêmes termes si le Parlement réunion
en congrès l'approuve ce sera la
première révision constitutionnelle
depuis près de 16 ans si le conditionnel
est de rigueur c'est parce que nous
devons mesurer combien le parcours d'une
révision constitutionnelle est difficile
celui-ci a débuté il y a plusieurs mois
grâce aux deux propositions de loi
constitutionnelle déposé tant par la
majorité et Madame berger que par
l'opposition et Madame Panau ce fut
l'bauche du consensus que nous devons
concrétiser aujourd'hui malgré des
résistances anciennes
oui pour parvenir à réformer la
Constitution il faut un consensus nous
l'avions trouvé en novembre 2022 ici
même le Sénat de son côté avait ad une
autre rédaction sans remettre en cause
le principe d'inscription de la liberté
garantie aux femmes de recourir à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
le projet loi présenté par le
gouvernement opère une synthèse qui nous
donne l'opportunité de cette révision
consécration de la liberté de la femme
et du rôle prépondérant du législateur
pour l'encadrer recours garanti à cette
liberté pour se prémunir de toute
régression
inscription littérale de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse au cœur de la
Constitution
les travaux menés par la commission des
lois la semaine passée éclairés par
l'avis du Conseil d'État ont je crois
permis à chacun de mesurer les enjeux et
de lever les dernières réserves pour
celles qui sont
sincères certains dans notrees
Commission ont raillé le caractère
symbolique d'une telle révision
constitutionnelle mais si elle n'était
que symbolique pourquoi alors s opposé
et la vérité c'est que réviser la
Constitution c'est tout sauf symbolique
la révision de 2007 constitutionnalisant
l'interdiction de la peine de mort
n'était pas symbolique la protection
d'une liberté fondamentale n'est pas
symbolique tout comme la définition du
caractère indivisible laïque
démocratique social de notre République
l'égalité devant la loi de tous les
citoyens sans distinction d'origine de
race ou de religion et le respect de
toutes les croyances consacrées à
l'article 1er de notre Constitution ne
sont pas des symboles mais des droits
garantis des droits auxquels le renons
institutionnelle confère la plus haute
protection qui soit pour les mettre à
l'abri de toute menace car
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
comme plusieurs droits fondamentaux
d'ailleurs est remise en cause dans le
monde la France n'étant pas isolée
hermétique ou autarcique au monde rien
ne l'a prémuni par principe des
mouvements conservateurs ou
réactionnaires des mouvements Provis
antiivg car en l'état du droit qui
pouvait prédire avec CER Sud l'adoption
de l'arrêt d'hobs de la Cour suprême des
États-Unis le 24 juin 2022 rompant avec
59 ans de reconnaissance fédérale du
droit à l'avortement en Amérique qui
peut sereinement observer la Hongrie et
la Pologne pourtant membre de l'Union
européenne restreindre avec force le
recours à l'IVG en obligeant les femmes
à écouter le cœur du féus en interdisant
les avortements en cas de malformation
et nul besoin pour leur détracteurs de
dénoncer cette fois la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme ni la Cour de
justice de l'Union européenne aucune
d'entre elles ne protège le droit à
l'IVG considérant que sa mise en œuvre
relève de la libre appréciation des
états aussi vrai soit-il qu'en France
l'avortement est largement soutenu par
la population comme par les associations
les mouvements antichoix sont bien
présents et se sont sinistrement
rappelés à la mémoire de tous en
dégradant plusieurs accueils du planning
familial dont je soulligne ici
l'importance et le rôle indispensable
aussi vrai soit-il qu'en France loi
reconnaî le recours à l'IVG aucune règle
constitutionnelle ne protège aujourd'hui
cette liberté le Conseil constitutionnel
n'a en effet jamais consacré cette
liberté ni estimé qu'elle était garantie
aux femmes la la conformité de l'IVG à
la Constitution ne résulte pas même d'un
principe constitutionnel spécifique mais
de l'équilibre entre la liberté de la
femme interprétation extensive de
l'article 2 de la Constitution de la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyens et de la sauvegarde de la
dignité de la personne humaine et à
titre de rappel préventif pour ceux à
qui cela échapperait dans les prochains
jours le Conseil constitutionnel
lui-même estime qu'il ne dispose pas
d'un pouvoir général d'appréciation et
de décision identique à celui du
Parlement mention consacrée depuis 1975
et sa décision relative à l'IVG dit
autrement seul le Parlement agissant en
constituant peut élever la protection du
recours à l'IVG au rang de principe
constitutionnel nous voilà donc placé
devant une responsabilité importante et
au regard de la du marche du monde
peut-être même historique la main de
celles et ceux qui nous ont précédé
comme Simone veille n'a pas tremblé
quand il a fallu adopter la loi de
1975 la voie de celles et ceux qui se
sont battu ne s'est jamais tu lorsque
tel GIS laimi il a fallu chairement
choisir la cause des femmes la nôtre ne
doit donc pas manquer au moment de
garantir constitutionnellement le
recours à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse je vous remercie je vous
remercie monsieur le Président la parole
est à présent à Madame vonique Roton
présid de la délégation au droits des
femmes et à l'égalité des chances entre
les hommes et les
[Applaudissements]
femmes
merci madame la présidente madame et
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président de la Commission monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues c'est avec
émotion et détermination que je me tiens
ici devant vous 50 ans après le discours
de Simone veille à cette même
pour garantir la pérennité du droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
en cet instant j'ai une pensée pour
toutes ces femmes connu inconnu qui ont
uvré pour faire entrer ce droit
fondamental à disposer de notre corps
dans notre loi pour toutes celles et
ceux qui accompagnent au quotidien
celles qui ont recours à l'avortement et
aussi pour toutes les Françaises de
notre pays qui nous écoutent avec
attention et amplie d'espoir comme le
disait Simone veille il suffit d'écouter
les femmes premières concernées par l'IV
g or 80 % des Françaises et des Français
sont en faveur de la
constitutionnalisation
écoutonsles je le répéterai autant de
fois que j'en aurai la force et n'en
déplaise à certains du côté de notre
hémicycle le droit à l'avortement n'est
pas un simple une simple tolérance ou
une grâce faite aux femmes l'IVG est un
droit fondamental un droit humain
fondamental celui de disposer librement
de notre corps et de choisir si oui ou
non nous voulons poursuivre une
grossesse les droits sexuels et
reproductifs sont le socle de tous les
droits des femmes comme le disait
Giselle Alimi il y a le droit à
l'avortement de la femme une
revendication élémentaire physique de
liberté je sais que certains d'entre
vous minoritaires s'interrogent
légitimement sur la nécessité de
constitutionnaliser ce droit à ceux qui
doutent je voudrais vous rappeler que
l'histoire du droit de l'avortement est
jalonnée de victoire mais aussi de
régression
qui aurait pu penser il y a 2 ou 3 ans
que le droit à l'avortement serait
torpillé aux États-Unis je sais que
certains d'entre vous me rétorqueront
qu'on écrit pas la loi en fonction de la
situation internationale à cela je veux
répondre deux choses premièrement je
vous l'affirme les mouvements antichoix
sont parmi nous il n'y a qu'à voir les
votes au sein de cet hémicycle dans
certains certains propos tenus en
commission des lois ou la mobilisation
grandissante autour de la marche pro vie
pour se rendre compte que le dooit l'IVG
n'est pas une évidence pour toutes et
tous deuxièmement et c'est précisément
parce que le droit l'IVG n'est pas
encore remis en cause en France que nous
pouvons et nous devons inscrire ce droit
dans la Constitution dès maintenant
chers collègues soyons humbl assumons
que ce droit à l'avortement qui nous é
cher pourrait disparaître en Europe on
l'observe déjà les forces politiques qui
sont opposées le remettent clairement en
cause dès leur arrivée au pouvoir ce
qu'une simple loi ordinaire nous nous a
permis d'obtenir il y a 50 ans une
simple loi ordinaire pourrait le défaire
ayons la modestie de reconnaître que ce
qui arrive chez nos voisins italiens
hongrois polonais qui ne sont pas des
contrées exotiques et lointaines comme
on a pu l'entendre en commission cela
peut aussi arriver en France l'avis du
Conseil d'État est très clair et doit
servir de base commune pour nos débats
personne ni aucun texte ne peut
aujourd'hui nous assurer de
l'intangibilité du droit de recourir à i
VG que celles et ceux qui refusent
d'intégrer le droit à l'IVG dans notre
Constitution parce qu'ils estiment qu'il
n'y a aucune menace aujourd'hui mais
qu'il regardent autour d'eux qu'il
regardent à l'horizon pouvez-vous
assurer aux générations futures qu'elles
auront accès au mêmes droits que nous
pouvez-vous le leur
garantir nous connaissons toutes et tous
la réponse le sujet est trop grave
faisons preuve d'honnêteté
intellectuelle vous qui clamez que les
conditions d'accès à l'IVG sont
prioritaires comment vous jus comment
vous justifiez avoir déposé des
amendements visant à amoindrir le droit
actuel comment vous expliquez aux
françaises et aux Français votre volonté
de diminuer le nombre de semaines durant
lesquelles il est possible d'avancer
d'avorter à 10 contre 14 aujourd'hui de
vouloir dérembourser l'IVG et chers
collègues la liste n'est pas terminée
créer un nouveau droit à la protection
de la vie à naître ce sont les mots des
antichoix qui ont filé ce dimanche dans
la rue quel choc en lisant vos
amendements quelle vision vous avez du
droit à l'avortement et des femmes que
les femmes seraient trop légères
lorsqu'elles ont recours à l'avortement
qu'elles ne seraient pas capables de
faire ce choix libre et éclairé ces
sous-entendus sont d'une violence
extraordinaire pour les concernés et
j'ai une pensée pour toutes celles
d'entre nous au sein même de cette
hémicycle et au-delà qui ont eu recours
à
l'IVG disons les choses clairement ce ce
discours qui vise à culpabiliser les
femmes est le témoignage d'une vision
paternaliste et rétrograde qui n'est ni
l'allié des femmes ni de leur liberté
vous nous faites croire qu'il n'existe
aucune menace au droit à l'IVG mais vous
incarnez vous-même cette menace vos
amendements sont la preuve même de la
nécessité de constitutionnaliser l'IVG
chers collègues n'attendons pas que le
droit à l'IVG soit en danger pour agir
agissons maintenant pour que ce droit ne
soit jamais en danger mon cœur mon corps
mon choix constitutionnalisons
l'IVG je vous remercie madame la
[Musique]
Présidente la parole est à présent à
Monsieur Jean-Félix aqu viiva pour le
groupe liberté indépendante outremer et
territoire pour une durée de 10
minutes madame la présidente monsieur le
garde des saau madame la ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
des lois monsieur le rapporteur madame
la présidente de la délégation aux
droits des femmes comment ne pas évoquer
ce soir solennellement à mon tour la
grande dame que fut Madame Simone veille
qui prenait la parole ici même il y a
près de 50 ans comment ne pas aussi se
remémorer l'adversité et la haine
qu'elle a enduré jusque dans ses propres
rangs si ce texte majeur en faveur du
droit des femmes a traversé les des
années personne ou très peu de gens
souhaitent le remettre en cause
aujourd'hui hormis quelques militants
acharnés que je respecte totalement à
partir du moment où il ne verse pas dans
un fanatisme
religieux cela étant à ceux qui disent
qu'il n'existe pas de risque réel et
imminent politique nous répondrons que
l'improbable n'est pas impossible et que
si l'optimisme est une qualité elle doit
pas mener à
l'aveuglement comment rester insensible
face aux positions réactionnaires de
divers gouvernements que l'on voit
poindre en Europe même sans compter
évidemment la décision de la Cour
suprême de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique dans ce contexte ce débat
et le vote de cette loi apporteront nous
le souhaitons un message
rassurant aussi plus d'un an après le
vote de la dernière proposition de loi
sur le thème ma position personnelle
mais celle ai de la très grande majorité
de notre groupe n'ont pas changé il est
important d'être constant et de rester
fidèle à ses convictions sur des sujets
de société aussi
important nous sommes favorables à
l'inscription dans la Constitution
française du droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse pour toutes les
femmes j'en profite pour saluer mon
collègue de la riège Laurent panifous
très engagé sur ces questions du droit à
l'IVG saisissons cette fenêtre de de tir
qui se présente à nous je le répète dans
cet hémicycle comme je l'ai fait en
commission au nom du groupe nous ne
pouvons manquer cette opportunité je ne
peux donc qu'en appeler à la
bienveillance de nos collègues sénateurs
et du président Gérard Larcher nous
n'enlevons aucun droit à personne nous
consacrons simplement une liberté
légitime je répondrai à ceux qui
estiment notre droit suffisamment
protecteur en leur disant que cette
vision ne doit pas mener à la béatitude
inconsciente la loi veille est une
grande loi
elle nen reste pas moins une loi
ordinaire qui pourrait être limitée par
une autre loi ordinaire nous pouvons
aller plus loin aujourd'hui en lui
conférant une force constitutionnelle
incontestable s'il existe une majorité
dans cette assemblée pour voter ce texte
alors cela do nous pousser non pas à
l'inertie mais renforcer la protection
de ce droit j'en viens à présent au
texte que nous propose le gouvernement
et et cette majorité comme je l'avais
dit en commission peut y voir une forme
de prudence un peu excessive l'article
unique reste c'est vrai timide par
rapport à la version que nous avions
soutenue en novembre 2022 porté par de
nombreux députés dont Mathilde Panau
mais pour des raisons d'équilibre nous
sommes prêts à nous ranger s'il le faut
et il le faudra certainement derrière
cette rédaction de compromis qui
privilégie la notion de liberté garantie
et une inscription à l'article 34 de la
Constitution
au-delà des avancées symboliques notre
groupe rappelle que la question
essentielle pour les citoyennes est
celle de l'exercice concret et sans
entrave de l'IVG il existe encore des
difficultés pratiques et des fractures
sociales et territoriales élevé dans
l'accès effectif à l'IVG qui impose une
réponse forte de l'État nous le savons
tous je finirai par une interrogation
générale la Constitution de 1958
contrairement par par exemple à la
Constitution de la République fédérale
allemande ne contient pas de liste de
droits et libertés qui sont nous le
savons renvoyés à ce que l'on appelle le
bloc de
constitutionnalité la question de l'IVG
qui nous occupe aujourd'hui montre bien
que la sacralisation de droits et
libertés fondamentaux est un
chantier que l'on doit selon nous
impérativement ouvrir pour clarifier les
chos en faveur d'une révision
constitutionnelle d'ampleur ceci étant
faisons tous aujourd'hui choix noble et
juste votons ce texte je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame Sarah tanzili pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
Renaissance
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le garde des saau monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
présidente de la délégation au droits
des femmes chers collègues il y a près
d'un demi-siècle cette assemblée
légalisait le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse sous l'impulsion
de Simon veille marquant ainsi le
commencement d'une nouvelle ère pour les
femmes
celle de la maîtrise de leur corps de la
maîtrise de leur
destin depuis cet acte fondateur pour
les droits des femmes dans notre pays
que de chemin parcourus le droit à
l'avortement a été renforcé et facilité
son remboursement a été mis en œuvre et
il ne fait aucun doute que toutes les
politiques d'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes dans notre pays n'auraient
pas été possible sans ce pas
décisif il appartient aujourd'hui à
cette législature de consacrer ce droit
pilier de édifice législatif
émancipateur des femmes en inscrivant
dans notre Constitution la liberté
garantie à la femme de recourir à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
si plusieurs groupes parlementaires ont
pris l'initiative de déposer une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle et
je tiens à les saluer ils ont tous
souligné la nécessité de privilégier le
recours à un projet de loi ces
propositions de loi eurent le mérite de
permettre à nos deux chambres de
débattre sereinement et comme il s'y
était engagé au terme d'une première
navette le président ident de la
République a déposé un projet de loi
constitutionnel en conseil des ministres
à ce stade je tiens à saluer monsieur le
Gard desau votre engagement constant en
faveur de l'inscription dans la
Constitution du droit de recourir à
l'IVG ainsi que votre détermination sans
borne madame la ministre et nous nous
souvenons tous du discours profondément
sincère et combatif que vous aviez tenu
ici il y a plus d'un an lorsque vous
faisiez encore partie des membres de
cette Assemblée à l'occasion de l'examen
d'une première proposition de loi
constitutionnalisant le droit à l'IVG je
tiens tient également à saluer la
qualité du rapport rédigé par vos soins
monsieur le rapporteur à sa lecture et à
la lumière de la vie particulièrement
éclairant du Conseil d'État les
conséquences juridiques de cette
inscription dans la Constitution sont
claires d'abord ils permettent de
répondre à ceux qui arguent du fait que
l'inscription de l'IVG dans la
Constitution est
superféatoire le Conseil d'État est venu
clarifier sans aucune ambiguïté le fait
qu'il n'existe pas en l'état actuel de
notre droit de garantie supra
législative la liberté donnée aux femmes
de recourir à l'avortement certes le
juge constitutionnelle a bien affirmé
que la législation actuelle en matière
d'IVG est conforme à la Constitution
mais il n'a jamais affirmé qu'une loi
qui viendrait réduire ou faire
disparaître ce droit de l'ordonnancement
juridique serait contraire à notre loi
fondamentale il est donc
incontestablement essentiel de passer
par une disposition claire qui consacre
cette liberté dans la
Constitution ensuite sur la formulation
retenue la loi détermine les conditions
dans lesquelles s'exerce la liberté
garantie à la femme d'avoir recours
cours à une interruption volontaire de
grossesse là aussi vos travaux monsieur
le rapporteur ainsi que ceux du Conseil
d'État sont précieux d'abord sur l'usage
du mot liberté plutôt que du mot droit
je reprendrai les éléments de l'avis du
Conseil d'État qui indique au vu de la
jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnelle qui ne retient pas une
acception différente des termes de droit
et de liberté le Conseil d'État
considère que la consécration d'un droit
à recourir à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse n'aurait pas une portée
différente de la proclamation d'une
liberté je vous diraiis aussi que la
Constitution consacre bien la liberté
d'expression ou la liberté de conscience
qui sont des droits fondamentaux dont
nul ne conteste la portée quand bien
même il ne s'agit pas d'un droit à
proprement parler sur le choix du mot
femme cette fois de même l'avis du
Conseil d'État est tout aussi éclairant
si la désignation d'un bénéficiaire de
cette liberté est indispensable pour
donner un caractère personnel à celle-ci
l'usage du mot femme somm tout assez
légitime L lorsqu'on parle de droits
reproductif n'empêche en aucun cas de
faire de toute personne en état de
grossesse un bénéficiaire de cette
liberté enfin le choix du gouvernement
de reprendre les travaux du Sénat sur
l'inscription de cette liberté à
l'article 34 de notre Constitution tout
en précisant que la liberté de recourir
à l'IVG est garantie aux femmes me
semble être tout à fait pertinent et de
nature à calibrer avec justesse le
niveau de protection de cette liberté
car cet équilibre permet de consacrer
les prérogatives du législateur pour
délimiter les contours et les modalités
d'exercice de ce droit tout en donnant à
la Constitution le soin d'en protéger le
caractère
effectif si ce projet de loi est adopté
il n'en résultera pas la nécessité de
faire évoluer notre cadre législatif il
n'en résultera en aucun cas un droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
en dehors du cadre législatif actuel il
n'en résultera pas non plus une remise
en cause d'autres droits et libertés et
en particulier de la liberté de
conscience des médecins il ne sera en
revanche pas possible pour un
législateur réactionnaire d'interdire le
droit à l'avortement ou de le limiter de
manière
excessive cette rédaction fruit d'un
premier échange entre les deux chambres
de notre Parlement est donc bien une
rédaction de compromis mais elle est
surtout d'une redoutable
efficacité permettre la mise en place
d'un bouclier protecteur non régressif
empêcher tout retour en arrière qui
viendrait privé d'effectivité le droit
des femmes de recourir à
l'IVG je peux comprendre que certains de
nos collègues très engagé sur ce sujet
soit tenté de vouloir améliorer la
rédaction proposée mais je voudrais leur
répondre que les deux chambres ont déjà
eu l'occasion d'exprimer leur volonté
que le mieux est l'ennemi du bien et
qu'à partir du moment où le terme
garantie a été ajouté à la formulation
du Sénat et ce terme est tout à fait
fondamental il ne fait aucun doute
qu'elle offre un niveau de protection
suffisant il nous faut donc en tirer les
conclusions appropriées et voter ce
texte sans modification pour tendre la
main à nos collègues sénateurs et parce
que toute modification nous éloignerait
de la perspective d'une
constitutionnalisation c'est ce que fera
le groupe Renaissance voter ce texte
sans rien y ajouter sans rien y
retrancher juridiquement la situation
est claire politiquement elle est aussi
malheureus
certains pensent qu'il ne s'agit que
d'une mesure purement symbolique et
qu'aucune menace ne pèse sur le droit à
l'IVG je leur répondrait deux choses la
première c'est que le bon moment pour
inscrire une liberté dans notre loi
fondamentale c'est lorsque nous avons
une majorité pour le faire après il est
trop tard la seconde c'est que non il
est faux de considérer que la menace est
nulle parce que l'humilité impose de
regarder avec lucidité ce qui se passe
hors du territoire français et de
constater que partout les réactionnaires
lorsqu'ils arrivent au pouvoir portent
atteinte à ce droit car il constitue un
pilier essentiel de la capacité des
femmes à maîtriser leur corps et leur
destin il y a eu l'arrêt d'obs aux
États-Unis qui nous rappelle qu'une
tradition juridique bien ancrée peut
être modifiée par une minorité très
organisée mais ce n'est pas qu'une
affaire américaine comme on l'entend
parfois au Portugal les conservateurs
ont limité les conditions accès à l'IVG
en Hongrie ils ont quasiment fait
disparaître ce droit et en Pologne il a
été pratiquement aboli dans les faits
suppression totale partielle
dboursements mesures vexatoires comme
l'imposition d'un examen psychologique
de délais de réflexion ou obligation
d'entendre au préalable les battements
de cœur du du fetus parout les
adversaires de l'IVG multiplie les
attaques contre ce droit y compris en
Europe que toutes les les défenseurs du
droit à l'avortement en Europe qui
militent parfois dans des conditions
très difficiles soit ici salués et
encourager leur combat est le nôtre
parce qu'il faudrait être aveugle ou de
mauvaise foi pour ne pas voir que la
menace est réelle ici aussi en France
non les antiivg dans notre pays n'ont
pas disparu il pululent sur les réseaux
sociaux et sur internet ils envoient des
féus en plastique aux députés engagés
sur cette question
6 à 15000 d'entre eux ont défilé dans
nos rues la semaine dernière ils sont
même parmi les rangs de notre assemblée
car n'oublions pas que si la stratégie
de la cravate change l'apparence elle ne
change rien au fond oui l'extrême droite
est l'adversaire historique du droit des
femmes en général et du droit à
l'avortement en particulier Marine Le
Pen défendait il y a encore quelques
années le déremboursement de l'IVG
considérant qu'il fallait lutter contre
je cite les avortements de confort en
2021 lorsque cette assemblée allonga le
délai de 12 à 14 semaines elle dénoncait
une dérive idéologique on attend
d'ailleurs toujours sa condamnation de
l'interdiction de l'avortement en
Pologne par ses alliés du PCE je crois
donc que nous pouvons je je pardon je
crois donc que nous pouvons avoir des
doutes légitimes quant au fait que ce
sont les idées du RN qui échangé sa soif
de pouvoir plutôt qui pousse ses membres
à dissimiler leur croyance profonde
derrière des cravates pourtant c'est
bien une élu RN qui avait qualifié en
2018 l'avortement de génocide de
français remplacé à tour de bras par les
migrants et c'est Horn qu'un député a
comparé en 2020 l'IVG à l'achoa au
génocide arménien et rwandais et au
crimes de
daesh à ceux qui disent que cette
constitutionnalisation ne sert à rien je
leur poserai cette question veulent-ils
sérieusement prendre le risque le risque
de voir demain leurs filles et leurs
petites filles mettre leur vie entre les
mains de feuseuses d'ange se retrouver
dans une arrière cuisine et finir
mutiler ou même pire simplement parce
qu'elle ne pouvaient pas se résoudre
àener à terme leur grossesse ce n'est ni
mon choix ni celui de mon groupe pour
consacrer le droit des femmes à
maîtriser leur corps pour envoyer un
message d'espoir à toutes les femmes du
monde qui voit leur droits reproductifs
fragilisés le groupe Renaissance votera
ce texte sans modification je vous
remercie je vous remercie ma cher
collègu la parole est à Madame Pascale
bord pour le rassemblement
national jeisessay de le remonter est-ce
que je peux un peu plus parce que je n'y
vois rien
voilà madame la présidente monsieur le
garde des saau madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues vouloir inscrire dans la
Constitution la liberté de la femme de
recourir à l'IVG est à tout le moins
inapproprié et inutile inapproprié car
ce texte est très éloigné des
aspirations actuelles de nos concitoyens
qui sont davantage
préoccupés par la hausse galopante des
prix par la Haus pente des prix
notamment de l'énergie et la baisse
corrélative du pouvoir d'achat par le
sort plus que préoccupant des pêcheurs
des agriculteurs sacrifiés sur l'hôtel
de l'Union européenne par la situation
internationale inquiétante par la hausse
exponentielle des trafics en tout genre
des viols des homicides que par la
constitutionnalisation d'un texte
parfaitement inutile et surtout
totalement décorrélé de tous ces sujets
qui ne vous intéressent pas mais qui
inquiètent au plus haut point nos
concitoyens texte inutile ensuite car
personne ne souhaite dans la société
française contemporaine remettre en
cause l'IVG notamment aucun aucun parti
politique au Parlement ne vous en
déplaise je le
répète car je connais si ce n'est je
n'ose pas le dire et je mettrai des
guillemet la mauvaise foi à ou le moins
la vision partielle et partiale parfois
sur nos bancs il n'est pas question que
notre famille politique remette en cause
l'accès à l'avortement la liberté de la
femme d'avorter est aujourd'hui
pleinement protégé par la loi portée par
Simone veille et elle fait désormais
partie
intégrante partie intégrante de notre
patrimoine juridique le Conseil
constitutionnel quant à lui a toujours
jugé l'avortement conforme à la
Constitution et il rattache au demeurant
livg à la liberté de la femme découlant
de l'article 2 de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen qu'il
concilie avec le principe de sauvegarde
de la dignité de la personne humaine
ainsi sur le plan constitutionnel il n'y
a strictement aucun risque d'atteinte à
l'IVG dès lors à quel titre à quel titre
devrions-nous modifier notre
Constitution afin d'y inscrire une
libert
que personne ne conteste et qui est
protégé par la jurisprudence constante
du Conseil constitutionnel que vous
savez brandir en d'autres occasions à
cet égard ne vous trompez pas de débat
comme certains tentent de le faire le
problème n'est pas de savoir si l'on est
pour ou contre l'IVG ce débat a été
tranché en 1975 il y a bientôt 50 ans
mettez vos pendules à l'heure il est de
savoir il est de savoir si l'on
constitutionnalise ou pas la liberté
d'avoir recours à une ivergé liberté que
personne ne conteste au demeurant et qui
est efficiente dans notre pays où
234300 IVG ont été pratiqués en 2022
soit deux fois plus qu'en Allemagne par
ailleurs c'est également un texte qui
risque de remettre en cause l'équilibre
de la loi veille en effet la loi veille
énonce dans son article 1er la loi
garantit le respect de tout être humain
dès le commencement de la vie il ne
saurait être porté atteinte à ce
principe qu'en cas de nécessité et selon
les conditions ont défin par la présente
loi à travers cet article le législateur
de 1975 il y a 50 ans quasiment a
souhaité équilibrer les droits de la
femme enceinte et ceux de l'embryon en
posant une règle et c'est fondamental
une règle dérogatoire au respect de tout
être humain dès le commencement de la
vie la loi veille était donc dès
l'origine un texte dérogatoire au droits
commun faisant de l'IVG une exception au
principe de respect de tout être humain
dès le commencement de la vie or vouloir
inscrire aujourd'hui dans notre
Constitution la liberté garantie à la
femme d'avoir recours à une IVG peut
apparaître en contradiction avec la loi
veille si le texte proposé est voté si
l'IVG est constitutionnalisé d'exception
elle deviendra principe et c'est tout un
pan du code de la santé publique et du
droit médical qu'il nous faudra rebtir
autour de ce principe quoi qu'en disent
les partisans de ce texte et ce afin
d'assurer à tout Pr cette nouvelle
liberté constitutionnelle au regard de
l'état actuel de notre système de santé
est-ce bien judicieux d'cun pour Pier
cet accueil mettent en avant l'aspect
symbolique de la démarche c'est
d'ailleurs pour sa portée symbolique
qu'une majorité de notre groupe a voter
en faveur du texte soumis à notre
assemblée en novembre 2022 comme la
Constitution est le texte suprême de
notre droit nous considérons que ce
texte devrait dans tous les cas être
soumis à un référendum car la
institution ne devrait pouvoir être
modifié que directement par le peuple
souverain d'autre part comme Marine Le
Pen l'a souligné durant la campagne
présidentielle les sujets je savais que
ça vous plairait les sujets de société
doivent être tranchés directement par la
société en outre certains
constitutionnalistes estiment
qu'inscrire cette liberté dans la
Constitution n'est pas responsable car
la norme constitutionnel doit être un
point d'ancrage de notre droit un
élément de stabilité de l'ordre
juridique et non l'exutoire des désirs
de certains cette nouvelle liberté
risque par ailleurs d'entrer en conflit
et c'est fondamental avec d'autres
libertés garanties par le bloc
constitutionnel je pense par exemple à
la liberté de conscience garantie par
l'article 10 de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen de
1789 enfin la formulation retenue la
liberté garantie liberté garantie à la
femme d'avoir recours à une IVG pourrait
conduire à consacrer un accès sans
conditions à l'IVG c'est le même débat
que celui que nous avons eu il y a
quelques mois comme par exemple des IVG
bien au-delà de la limite légale en
vigueur à ce sujet quelques amendements
déposés par certains groupes
parlementaire toujours à la pointe
d'innovation laisse à penser que d'aucun
ne verrait absolument pas d'inconvénient
à la pratique d'IVG jusqu'à 8 ou 9 mois
de grossesse alors pourquoi ce texte
pourquoi ce texte tout en reconnaissant
que cette liberté des nullement menacé
dans notre pays on invoque désormais tel
un inventaire à la prêverre une croisade
que notre pays se devrait entreprendre
partout dans le monde l'utilisation du
terme croisade par le rapporteur
souligne ainsi le caractère très
idéologique de ce texte le fait que la
France serait ainsi l'un des premiers
pays et le premier pays en Europe enfin
la volonté du chef de l'État j'ai gardé
le meilleur pour la fin d'adresser un
message universel de solidarité à toutes
les femmes qui voont aujourd'hui cette
liberté bafouée or la sauvegarde des
droits et des libertés des femmes ne se
réduit pas à un sombre concours pour
savoir qui est le premier ni a une
croisade à travers le monde et encore
moins un message universel donné à la
terre entière voire à la galaxie à
forciorie lorsque ces mêmes droits et
libertés ne sont pas loin sans faux
efficients en France il en est fini de
la défense des droits des femmes place
au message politique au tracte de
campagne électorale les FEM ou qu'ell
vivent dans le monde mérite mieux que
cette vulgaire course à la gloriole pour
conclure ce texte inapproprié inutile et
contraire à à l'équilibre de la loi
veille ne permettra par ailleurs en
aucune façon de résoudre la question
majeure la question majeure de
l'effectivité de l'accès à l'IVG sur
tout le territoire français où près de
50 ans après la loi veille nombre de
femmes en secteur rural essentiellement
ne parviennent pas à avoir REC cours à
une IVG dans les délais légaux repoussé
récemment jusqu'à 14 semaines pour
palier pour palier les carences habissal
de notre système de santé dès lors ce
texte ce texte ne règlera pas au
quotidien le problème de toutes ces
femmes car il ne s'agit là que d'une
opération de communication destinée à
flatter l' Go de certains tout en
masquant la réalité de l'insondable état
de notre système de santé bref ce texte
final n'est qu'un artifice pour marquer
la vacuité de votre politique de défense
du droit des femmes farouchement
attaquer farouchement attaché à la
liberté de conscience le groupe
rassemblée nationale laissera voter
chacun en conscience mais chers
collègues ce sujet ce sujet est beaucoup
trop grave pour être instrumentalisé à
des fins politiciennes ne pas voter ce
texte n'est absolument pas une remise en
cause de l'accès à l'avortement nous
nous trompons pas de débatin qui fait
aujourd'hui partie intégrante de notre
patrimoine juridique je le répète quel
que soit notre vote nous sommes mes
chers collègues je le crois tous sur ces
bancs attachés à faire de la défense des
femmes une
priorité je vous
remercie la parole est à présent à
madame la Présidente pan pour le groupe
la France
insoumise
présidente ministre collègues
aujourd'hui la France parle au
monde aujourd'hui l'histoire longue
vient à notre rencontre et elle nous
appelle à prendre une décision qui soit
à la hauteur de ce que nous sommes
collectivement collègues c'est
aujourd'hui que nous devons consacrer le
droit à l'avortement dans la
Constitution d'cun nous disent pourtant
que nous serions réunis dans un but nul
et non avenu que constitutionnaliser
l'avortement ne serait ni urgent ni
majeur ni vital c'est nié qu'en 2024 en
France 49 ans après la loi veille le
droit à l'IVG n'est toujours pas
pleinement effectif c'est nié qu'en 2024
en France il est toujours difficile pour
des femmes d'accéder à un avortement
dans des délais convenables sans faire
des centaines de kilomètres avec la
méthode de son choix c'est nié qu'en
2024 en France 130 centres IVG ont fermé
en 15 ans et que l'accès à l'avortement
est toujours conditionné à une double
clause de conscience des médecins et ce
pourquoi parce que 49 ans après la loi
veille le combat des femmes pour le
droit à disposer de leur corps est plus
que jamais d'actualité collègu c'est
aujourd'hui que nous devons consacrer le
droit à l'avortement dans la
Constitution parce que 49 ans après la
loi veille nous restons dans un en même
temps insupportable de la part de ce
gouvernement a commencé par Emmanuel
Macron lui-même Emmanuel Macron qui il y
a une semaine n'a pas eu un mot en 2h20
de conférence de presse pour la
constitutionnalisation du droit à
l'avortement à l'inverse il aura préféré
en reprenant les mots de Victor Orban
Premier ministre hongrois d'extrême
droite se faire le chant du réarmement
démographique Victor Orban qui je le
rappelle impose aux femmes hongroises
d'écouter le cœur du fitus lorsqu'ellees
souhait mettre fin à une grossesse ce
même Victor Orban qui est d'ailleurs le
modèle de Jordane Bardella et du
rassemblement national qui à l'image de
tous les réactionnaires et fascistes à
travers l'histoire s'est saisi de la
question de la démographie pour
instrumentaliser le corps des femmes
collègues nos OV ne sont pas des armes
de guerre
oui monsieur le ministre madame la
ministre le corps des femmes
n'appartient ni à l'État ni à la famille
ni au juge mais aux femmes et à ell seul
l'obsession nataliste est lié depuis le
début à la criminalisation de
l'avortement le régime de Vichy avait
fait de l'avortement un crime contre la
sûreté de l'État passible de peine
capitale comme corollaire de sa
politique nataliste de tous les régimes
fascistes du siècle passé le contrôle de
la reproduction et la domination du
corps des femmes sont les premiers
leviers vers un état totalitaire
aujourd'hui partout dans le monde les
rétrogrades redouble encore de
stratégies pour restreindre et bafouer
les droits sexuels et reproductifs
collègues c'est aujourd'hui que nous
devons consacrer le droit à l'avortement
dans la Constitution car les mouvements
antichoix sont toujours une menace
féroce et organisé et il n'y a pas
d'exception française il manifeste il
désinforme massivement sur les réseaux
sociaux leurs militants attaquent de
plus en plus régulièrement les
permanences du planning familial ils
font campagne pour le déremboursement de
l'avortement ils combattent également
l'éducation à la vie affective et
sexuelle à l'école s'attaquant AINS par
là à la bonne information sur la
contraception à l'éducation au
consentement ou encore à la lutte contre
les inégalités ces antidroits siègent y
compris à l'extrême droite de cet
hémicycle au rassemblement national dont
le fondateur Jean-Marie Le Pen déclaré
en
1996 l'affirmation que votre corps vous
appartient est tout à fait dérisoire il
appartient à la vie et aussi en partie à
la nation le rassemblement national qui
en 2012 souhaité par la voix de Marine
Le Pen dérembourser les avortiments dit
de confort Marine Le Pen toujours qui en
2022 s'opposer à l'allongement du délai
légal pour avorter bande extrême droite
sur lequel on retrouve pelmel lor La
Valette qui écrit vouloir abroger à
terme le droit à l'avortement Hervé de
l'épino qui compare l'avortement au
génocide arménien et rwandais à la Choa
au crime de daesh Caroline Parmentier
qui regrette qu'après avoir génocidé les
enfants français à raison de 200000 par
an le nombre d'avortements en France on
doit maintenant les remplacer à tour de
bras par les migrants oui oui le danger
le pire danger pour les droits des
femmes c'est vous collègu voilà pourquoi
aujourd'hui nous devons consacrer le
droit à
l'avortement nous avons une
responsabilité immense l'avortement
n'est peut-être pas en danger imminent
peut-être inscrivonsle dans la
Constitution et il ne le sera jamais à
l'avenir car c'est justement quand il
n'est pas encore en danger imminent
qu'il faut le protéger introduire le
droit à l'avortement dans la
Constitution c'est ise la portée de ce
droit fondamental humain aujourd'hui
incertaine c'est affirmé ici à nos
enfants petits enfants arrière petits
enfants qu'elles n'auront pas moins de
droit que nous c'est conjuré l'idée que
les générations futures n'auront jamais
à inurgiret de l'eau oxygéné du
détergent ni à s'introduire dans
l'utérus une aiguille à tricoter une
brosse à dent de l'eau savonneuse ou un
épis de blé c'est paraî la réalité des
ces VI que les femmes pouvaient
s'infliger avant 1975
entre entraînant parfois leur mort car
oui la seule conséquence de la privation
des femmes du droit à avortter c'est
l'avortement clestin et bien souvent la
mort collègues voilà pourquoi c'est
aujourd'hui que nous devons consacrer le
droit à l'avortement être le premier
pays au monde à gravé dans sa
constitution le droit à l'avortement
honore la France comme une nation
pionnière des droits des femmes cette
consacration que nous appelons de nos
vœux aujourd'hui nous la voulons comme
un encouragement à la lutte et un
hommage aux femmes états-uniennes traqué
jusque dans leur conversation Facebook
et condamné pour des pilules abortives
un hommage aux femmes argentines en
grève générale aujourd'hui notamment
pour le droit à l'avortement cette
consécration que nous appelons de nos
vœux aujourd'hui nous la voulons comme
un hommage à Vanessa mendesa Cortez
traîné en justice pour avoir juste
dénoncé devant l'ONU la quasi
interdiction de l'avortement en odor
comme hommage à justina vidrinka
militante polonaise condamnée pour avoir
aidé une femme à avorter cette
concétration que nous appelons de nos
vœux aujourd'hui nous la voulons comme
hommage à Isabella à qui on a refusé
l'avortement et dans le dernier SMS
avant sa mort déclaré c'est la loi le
supplis de l'être humain les femmes sont
devenues des couveuses cette
consécration que nous appelons de nos
vœux aujourd'hui nous la voulons comme
un hommage aux personnes qui meurent
toutes les 9 minutes dans le monde du
fait d'un avortement non sécurisé
collègu voilà pourquoi c'est aujourd'hui
que nous devons consacrer le droit à
l'avortement
insoumise nous nous réclamons héritière
d'un humanisme dont le principe
directeur est l'autonomie c'est
l'autonomie individuelle consacrée par
les droits humains qui est à la base des
liberté de conscience d'expression de
mouvement c'est se commander à soi-même
être maître de soi être libre de choisir
il n'y a pas d'aspiration plus haute
pour tout être humain c'est pour cela
que le droit à l'avortement est le
préalable à tout féminisme
constitutionnaliser ce droit aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas juste défendre la justice
reproductive dans le monde c'est
défendre la démocratie celle d'être
sujet de sa vie car quel est le sujet du
féminisme non pas exclusivement les
femmes quel est le sujet du féminisme
une histoire multimillénaire de
l'émancipation collègu voilà pourquoi
aujourd'hui nous devons consacrer le
droit à
l'avortement la constitutionnalisation
de l'IVG parachève une longue histoire
de privation des femmes à disposer de
leur corps elle s'inscrit dans la
continuité de toutes les mobilisations
féministes cette victoire aujourd'hui
est d'abord celle de toutes les
militants des associations et des
collectifs je veux saluer leur présence
en tribune et leur dire notre
reconnaissance pour leur engagement à
faire vivre les droits des femmes au
quotidien militantes féministes de tout
temps si ce débat existe si cette
victoire est proche c'est d'abord grâce
à vos combats car derrière la loi il y a
toujours une foule c'est cette longue
foule de militante qui a arraché le
droit à l'IVG en
1975 c'est le combat de ces femmes qui
permet le remboursement de l'IVG par la
Sécurité Sociale en 1981 à 100 % en 2013
qui remporte l'allongement des délais de
10 à 12 semaines en 2001 puis de 12 à 14
semaines en 2022 c'est toujours cette
foule qui arrache victoire après
victoire les droits des mineurs à
avortter sans accord parental la
suppression du délai de réflexion la
création du délit d'entrave l'autor des
SA à pratiquer des IVG c'est aussi une
victoire insoumise et parlementaire
puisque la proposition que de loi que
j'avais eu l'honneur de porter pour mon
groupe avait été adopté le 24 novembre
2022 à l'Assemblée puis le 1er février
2023 au
Sénat ce qui a forcé le gouvernement à
inscrire ce projet de loi
constitutionnel à l'ordre du jour des
années 60 jusqu'au 3e
millénaire le droit à l'IVG est un champ
de bataille perman ant nous sommes
conscients qu'il y aura jamais de marbre
assez puissant pour graver
définitivement ce droit nous sommes
conscients que la formulation rotenu
n'est pas celle que nous aurions
souhaité le temps venu dans la
Constituante le peupleaméliorera et
ajoutera le droit à la contraception
corolaire du droit à l'avortement nous
sommes conscientses de tout cela mais
cette inscription dans la Constitution
marque une victoire historique cette
victoire est la vôtre la nôtre est la
défaite des
antichoix aujourd'hui la France parle le
monde pour terminer je souhaite vous
livrer les mots de Giselle Alimi lors de
sa pldoirie au procès de bobini en
1972 personne comprenez-moi monsieur
personne n'a jamais pu obliger une femme
à donner la vie quand quand elle a
décidé de ne pas le faire et comme un
symbole magnifique au moment où nous
discutons cette loi nous apprenons que
les militantes polonaises on vont
reconquérir l'accès libre à la pilule de
lendemain leur combat est le nôtre notre
victoire et la
leure merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Pan
merci la parole est à Madame Émilie
Bonivard pour le groupe les
républicains madame la
présidente madame la ministre monsieur
le ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues les représentants du peuple
français
d'exposer dans une déclaration
solennelle les droits naturels
inaliénables et sacrés de l'homme afin
que cette déclaration constamment
présente à tous les membres du corps
social leur rappel sans cesse leurs
droits et leurs devoirs ces mots sont
ceux du préambule de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen de
1789 nous constituant avons un devoir
fondamental veiller au respect de
l'esprit et de la lettre de cette
déclaration dès lors que nous nous
apprêtons à modifier notre
Constitution parmi les droit que la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme est du
citoyen qualifie de naturel et
imprescriptible figure notamment en son
article 2 la liberté c'est en s'appuyant
sur cet article que le Conseil
constitutionnel a jugé l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse comme principe à
valeur
constitutionnelle la liberté pour la
femme de mettre fin à sa grossesse est
déduit de ce droit fondamental à la
liberté dans leur immense sagesse nos
illustres prédécesseurs ont défini à
l'article 4 de cette même déclaration ce
qu'est cette
liberté ce droit naturel et
imprescriptible je cite la liberté
consiste à pouvoir faire tout ce qui ne
nuit pas à
autrui la liberté mentionnée n'est donc
pas absolue elle ne revient vient pas à
faire absolument tout ce que l'on veut
elle est limitée par le fait de ne pas
nuire à autrui et donc par un autre
droit fondamental le droit de toute
personne à la vie déduit de cette même
déclaration est mentionnée par l'article
2 de la Convention européenne de
sauvegarde des droits de l'homme et des
libertés fondamentales c'est précisément
cet équilibre fragile entre ces deux
libertés et ou droits fondamentaux que
la loi veille du 17 janvier 75 a réussi
à protéger le respect de la liberté de
la femme de mettre un terme à sa
grossesse et la protection du droit de
l'enfant à naître je souhaite rappeler
ici que dans son article 1er la loi
veille consacre je cite le principe du
respect de l'être humain dès le
commencement de sa vie la loi veille
c'est aussi cela tout en permettant à la
femme de mettre un terme à sa grossesse
à l'époque jusqu'à la 10e Semaine et
dans des conditions spécifiques comme la
détresse de la femme en somme la loi
veille prévoit qu'au cours des premières
semaines de la grossesse déterminé par
la loi c'est la liberté de la femme qui
prévaut mais qu'après la fin du délai de
l'IVG c'est la protection de l'enfant à
naître qui prévaut c'est donc cet
équilibre délicat ténu la conciliation
de ces deux principes fondamentaux que
nous devons préserver alors que nous
débattons de l'inscription de l'IVG dans
notre Constitution et à la lecture du
discours de Simon veille à cette tribune
il y a 49
ans je suis convaincu d'une chose c'est
que l'intention de Simon veille ne
relevait pas du militantisme je crois
que Simon veille visait comme
législatrice de manière pragmatique
responsable et humaine à mettre fin à
des situations de détresse inaccepable
pour les femmes alors que des pratiques
illégales d'IVG étaient courantes avec
tous les risques connus pour la vie et
la fertilité à venir des femmes elle
visait accorder le droit de l'époque à
une réalité sociale incontestable
elle visait ai aussi à mettre fin à la
peur et à la culpabilité de la femme
d'être hors la loi Valérie giscardestin
alors président de la République disait
au sujet de cette loi qu'elle visait à
mettre fin à une situation de désordre
et d'injustice et apportter une solution
mesurée et humaine à un des problèmes
les plus difficiles de notre temps sans
la volonté de Valérie Giscard desestin
sans le souhait de Jacques Chirac alors
Premier ministre sans l'humilité de
Simon veille sans la mobilisation
de députés sur tous ces bancs l'IVG
n'aurait pas été inscrit à l'ordre du
jour de notre assemblée et n'aurait pas
été voter je ne laisserai donc personne
durant ces débats avoir des propos
réducteurs à l'égal de la droite
républicaine des républicains que j'ai
l'honneur de représenter car la loi
veille de 75 et de très nombreux droits
relatifs au droits des femmes ont été
présentés et portés par des
gouvernements de droite en revanche oui
chez les
républicains nous revendiquons une
exigence forte celle de nous assurer que
toujours l'équilibre de la loi veille
soit respecté et de respecter la liberté
de conscience de chacun si à titre
personnel En tant que femme je suis
favorable à l'inscription de l'IVG dans
la Constitution comme législateur comme
constituant j'ai un devoir fondamental
prioritaire sur mon avis personnel et ma
condition genraé de
femme m'assurer que cette inscription de
l'IVG
à laquelle je suis favorable n'aboutisse
pas d'une manière ou d'une autre à la
négation à la réduction au grignotage
d'un autre droit fondamental qui est le
respect de la vie humaine car ces droits
n'ont pas à être hiérarchisés
humainement je ne pourrais l'accepter et
j'estime que je
suis un homme une femme au sens de la
Constitution et que je ne me réduitis
pas à mes
es or à ce stade un certain nombre de
doutes peuvent exister monsieur le
ministre notamment en raison de la
modification par le gouvernement de la
rédaction du texte de notre collègue
Philippe Bas président LR de la
commission des Lois du Sénat il avait su
trouver une rédaction de compromis votée
notamment par la gauche
sénatoriale si nous avions débattu du
texte du Sénat aujourd'hui nous aurions
eu je pense un vote conforme et un vote
rapide au
Congrès le gouvernement a voulu rajouter
dans sa rédaction que la liberté de la
femme d'avoir recours à i VG lui est
garanti aussi le gouvernement ouvre un
questionnement sur le caractère
opposable de cette liberté qui pourrait
risquer dans les faits et dans l'analyse
de compromettre un autre principe
fondamental qui est le respect de l'être
humain dès le commencement de sa vie
monsieur le ministre vous nous avez
rassuré dans vos propos liminires mais
nous aurons besoin d'être rassurés nous
avons dit en commission que nous
n'avions pas à nous inquiéter que l'avis
effectivement du Conseil d'État devait
nous rassurer or il n'en reste pas moins
monsieur le ministre que c'est nous qui
faisons la loi et en l'espèce qui
modifions la Constitution aussi j'aurais
besoin que vous nous précisiez que vous
nous expliquiez un cas très concret
comment pourra statuer pourrait statuer
le Conseil constitutionnel face au cas
suivant une femme ayant découvert sa
grossesse tardivement à la 12e semaine
par exemple vivant éloigné d'un centre
hospitalier ou n'ayant pas pu avoir
accès à un médecin ou une sage-femme
dans les temps puisqueon le sait
malheureusement ça arrive dans notre
territoire estime que sa liberté qui lui
est pourtant garantie par la
Constitution n'a pas été effective elle
demande donc d'avoir recours à l'IVG
hors délai que dira le juge
constitutionnel comment statuera-t-il
nous aurons besoin de vos réponses autre
doute aujourd'hui la liberté de la femme
à avoir recours à l'IVG est un principe
à valeur constitutionnel le respect de
l'être humain dès le commencement de sa
vie est également un principe à valeur
constitutionnel autrement dit ces deux
principes ont la même valeur au regard
de notre Constitution orors demain avec
avec ce texte l'IVG sera inscrit en
toute lettre dans un article de notre
Constitution et je le redis j'y suis
favorable mais en revanche le droit de
l'enfant à naître lui ne le sera pas que
dira le juge constitutionnel le jour où
il aura interpréter l'intention du
constituant dans ce qu'il a fait mais
également dans ce qu'il a décidé de ne
pas faire pourquoi ne pas avoir inscrit
dans les mêmes termes la liberté pour la
femme de recourir à l'IVG et le droit de
l'enfant à naître dans la Constitution
c'est sur ces doutes ou en tout cas ces
possibles interprétations que nous
aurons besoin d'être
rassuré il s'agit bien car il s'agit
bien collectivement chers collègues de
se tenir à l'écart de deux extrêmes qui
agissent au CIN de notre société et
malheureusement je ne souhaitais pas le
dire mais ayant suivant les les deux
précédentes interventions parfois au
sein de notre hémicycle
la la vision extrême selon laquelle le
droit de l'enfant à naître prévaut sur
la liberté de la femme et qu'à ce titre
l'IVG devrait être remis en cause et
l'autre vision extrême selon laquelle la
liberté absolue de la femme prévaut sur
le droit de l'enfant à naître et qu'à ce
titre IVG ne peut ne peut avoir aucune
limite je me demande dans quelle mesure
ces extrêmes ne se nourrissent pas l'un
l'autre c'est bien pour nous prémunir du
premier extrémisme que l'inscription de
l'IVG dans la Constitution est à l'ordre
du jour et que j'y suis favorable même
si l'IVG n'est pas en danger
juridiquement en France ce droit est
remis en cause dans la plus grande des
démocres s'il vous plaît le ce droit est
démocraties du monde les États-Unis de
même en Europe à quelques centaines de
kilomètres de notre pays en Pologne ou
en Hongrie on peut pas faire comme si
cela n'existait pas le pire n'est jamais
certain cert mais malheureusement
l'histoire nous a suffisamment démontrer
qu'il était possible c'est une réalité
une forme d'extrémiste dont il n'est pas
inconcru de se préserver par ce texte
mais nous devons aussi rejeter avec la
même force l'autre extrémisme et nous en
prévenir selon lequel le droit de la
femme est absolu et qu'il permettrait si
on le suit d'avoir recours à l'IVG à 6 7
voire 9 mois on a débattu ici d'un
amendement sur l'IMG en cas de d'une
détresse psychosociale qui a été sens
par le Conseil d'État ces forces
agissent dans notre société et dans
notre hémicycle et je crois qu'il est
très important et notre devoir essentiel
en tant que constituant de maintenir ces
extrêmes à égale distance de notre
travail pour maintenir l'équilibre de la
loi veille je vous remercie merci
beaucoup mes chers
[Musique]
collègues la parole est à présent à
monieur
pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
démocrate madame la présidente monsieur
le garde des saau monsieur le rapporteur
mes chers
collègues une nouvelle loi est-elle
vraiment
nécessaire ces mots vous l'aurez compris
ne sont pas les miens comme aujourd'hui
Simone veille avait dû justifier de la
nécessité de légiférer afin de
dépénaliser
l'avortement soyons fi aujourd'hui de
marcher dans ses pas et c'est non sans
émotion que nous nous retrouvons une
nouvelle fois pour défendre
l'inscription de la liberté de recourir
à l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
dans la Constitution je suis heureux
pour toutes les femmes mais aussi pour
tous les hommes de ce pays que nous nous
en débattions
aujourd'hui mais quelle humilité cela
impose quelle dignité cela demande et
j'espère que nous saurons collectivement
la voir tant le sujet est important tant
il touche l'intimité des
femmes n'oublions pas ce que cela
signifie aussi et hier comme aujourd'hui
il nous faut justifier la défense de ce
droit et la nécessité d'en garantir sa
protection le 24 novembre
32 voix ont voté contre la constitution
de la constitutionnalisation de l'IVG 32
voix sous couvert d'un d'une soi-disant
meilleure protection des femmes et de
leur intérêt tous les arguments avancé
nont en réalité que pour objet de
limiter ce droit cela
interroge cela effraie et cela illustre
malheureusement que ce droit que nous
pensons essentiel
etani
n'est pas hors d'atteinte y compris dans
nos démocraties cela justifie d'autant
plus l'impérieuse nécessité d'inscrire
ce droit fondamental dans la
Constitution car oui oui les antiivg
sont bien toujours présent et vindicatif
dans notre pays alors ne soyons pas
dupes et agissons c'est ce que nous
avons commencé à faire d'ailleurs et je
tiens à rendre hommage à tous les
groupes parlementaires qui
collectivement de façon transpartisane
nont fait que ce sujet arrive
aujourd'hui sur la table le 24 novembre
2022 notre assemblée adopté à une large
majorité transpartisan une proposition
de loi constitutionnelle garantissant
aux femmes l'effectivité de l'iéger
ainsi que son égal accès le 1er février
2023 le Sénat adopte à son tour cette
proposition de loi avec une nouvelle
rédaction le texte qui nous est proposé
aujourd'hui est le fruit d'un équilibre
entre nos deux positions retenant les
mots interruption volon volire de
grossesse afin de ne laisser substituer
aucune ambigué consacrant l'existence
d'une liberté et reconnaissant le
Parlement dans dans l'établissement des
conditions dans lesquelles s'exerce
cette liberté garantie par la
Constitution l'arrivée sur nos bandes ce
projet de loi constitutionnelle est le
véhicule législatif que nous attendions
elle marque ni plus ni moins la volonté
du gouvernement de la représentation
nationale d'aller au bout de ce
processus législatif grâce à un vote des
parlementaires qui seront réunis en
congrès c'est une aspiration de toute la
société plus de 80 % des Françaises et
des Français souhaitent cette
constitutionnalisation alors si Simon
veille avait malheureusement dû
s'excuser d'être une femme devant une
assemblée presque exclusivement composé
d'hommes je ne m'excuserai pas
aujourd'hui d'être un homme défendant la
liberté de de recouvrir à l'IVG d'une
part parce que c'est un honneur de le
faire devant de très nombreuses femmes
désormais assises dans cette hémicycle
et vous l'avez rappelé madame berger
c'était impossible il y a 50 ans d'autre
part parce que je suis convaincu que les
hommes doivent aussi se saisir de ce
sujet et de tous les sujets d'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes et
s'inspirant de
l'histoire de Marie-Louise girud une des
dernières femmes guillotinée une femme
guillotinée en France pour avoir été une
feiseuse d'ange Claude Chabrol avait
réalisé en
1988 un film magnifique une affaire de
femme aujourd'hui nous pouvons dire que
ce n'est pas seulement une affaire de
femme ni même une affaire de genre mais
bien une affaire de société je crois
fermement qu'il est de notre rôle de
législateur mais avant tout de citoyens
et de citoyennes de nous prononcer
résolument pour la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG il en va
de notre responsabilité et de notre
devoir de protéger la liberté de main de
nos filles et de nos petites filles à
disposer de leur corps poursivant les
propos de Simone veille je vous
rappellerai à mon tour qu'aucune femme
ne recourt de guêter de cœur à
l'avortement et croyez bien que sur ce
point je pense que rien n'a changé mais
jamais aucun jugement ne doit être porté
sur les raisons qui peuvent la pousser à
y recourir et l' de choc provoqué par la
décision historique de la Cour suprême
américaine bouleverse nos convictions et
brise le mouvement que l'on croyait
continu des progrès du droit des femmes
à disposer de leur corps nous devons
nous interroger sur notre capacité à
anticiper de tels revers en Europe et en
France son inscription dans notre norme
suprême lui offrira la protection la
plus forte qui soit elle rendra
autrement plus difficile les véléités de
certains de la remettre en cause par la
loi loi parce que oui quand nous
inscrivons quand nous inscrivons une
liberté dans la Constitution nous le
faisons pour l'avenir comme vous l'avez
dit monsieur le garde des saau monsieur
Larcher président du Sénat je je
m'adresse à vous oui la Constitution
n'est pas un catalogue de droits sociaux
et sociétaux vous avez raison mais la
Constitution est bien une définition de
droits fondamentaux qu'elle protège donc
oui l'IVG y a toute sa place
certains y voient là qu'un symbole
presque inutile et bien oui mes chers
collègues la constitutionnalisation de
la liberté de recourir à l'IVG par la
France est aussi un symbole ne nous
cachons pas là-dessus plus encore nous
sommes fiers de ce symbole nous sommes
fiers du message que cela ne manquera
pas d'envoyer aux autres pays et je suis
certain que d'autres pays suivront ce
mouvement parce qu'il y a bien un moment
pour lui rendre hommage c'est celui-ci
j'ai ouvert mon propos avec les mots de
Simone veille et je les terminerai
également avec les
siens l'histoire nous montre que les
grands débats qui ont divisé un moment
les Français apparaissent avec le recul
du temps comme une étape nécessaire à la
formation d'un nouveau consensus social
qui s'inscrit dans la la tradition de
tolérance et de mesure de notre pays
alors en mémoire de Simone veille en
mémoire de nos grands-mères et de nos
mères qui ont t souffert de ne pas avoir
ce droit à qui la liberté de disposer de
leur corps a tant manqué et demain pour
garantir ce droit à nos filles et nos
petites filles écrivons un nouveau
chapitre dans l'histoire des droits des
femmes constitutionnalisant le droit à
l'IVG je vous
remercie merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à présent à
Madame Marie Noë baptistel pour le
groupe
socialiste
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
présidente de la délégation au droits
des femmes chers collègues aujourd'hui
est un grand jour car chers collègues
nous pouvons ensemble écrire une page de
notre histoire il s'agit d'un grand jour
pour les femmes qui sont toujours
ballotées dans les soubressau de
l'histoire et qui de changement politiqu
en changement de régime ne sont jamais à
l'abri de voir leur droit reculer au
moment d'inscrire dans la Constitution
ce droit sacralisé il me plaît de citer
à cette tribune les les mots de Simone
de beauauvoir à l'adresse des des femmes
n'oubliez jamais qu'il suffira d'une
crise économique politique ou religieuse
pour que les droits des femmes soient
remis en question ces droits ne sont
jamais acquis vous devrez rester
vigilante votre vie durant aujourd'hui
nous pouvons faire triompher cette
vigilance ce grand jour est d'abord
celui des féministes celle des
associations celle du planning
familial celle de tous ces
professionnels qui se battent chaque
jour pour faire de l'avortement un droit
réel et effectif qui accompagne au
quotidien les femmes dans la
revendication et l'exercice de leurs
droits à disposer librement de leur
corps je veux les saluer ici pour leur
engagement leur combat c'est un grand
jour aussi pour les socialistes porteur
de plusieurs lois visant à renforcer à
protéger l'IVG en 2018 nous défendions
déjà un amendement pour reconnaître dans
le préambule de la Constitution de
1946 le droit d'avoir accès à une
contraception adaptée et gratuite ainsi
que de recourir librement à l'IVG
l'année suivante nous le reprenions sous
la forme d'une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle sur laquelle nous
n'avions malheureusement pas obtenu
l'aval de la majorité à l'époque mais
nous sommes ensemble aujourd'hui et
c'est une bonne nouvelle sur les rangs
de ceux qui veulent faire avancer les
droits des femmes je salue la constance
et l'engagement de mes collègues
Laurence Rossignol mais aussi Cécile
huntermeyer et Fatia kelouashi qui comme
moi n'ont jamais cessé de se battre pour
cette cause c'est aussi un grand jour
pour les groupes de gauche qui rassemblé
en fait adopter cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle par l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat ce qui nous amène
aujourd'hui à ce projet de loi
constitutionnel je salue mes partenaires
Mathilde Panau Elsa faussillon et
Marie-Charlotte Garin pour le engagement
pugas pour le droit des
femmes je salue également le rapporteur
Guillaume Gouffier vallence sur qui nous
avons toujours toujours pu nous appuyer
dans ce long parcours et toutes elles et
ceux qui parmi nous portent ce combat
alors ne laissons personne confisquer
cette victoire à ceux qui prétendent que
le droit d'avorter n'est pas de menacer
en France je rappelle les exemples des
SEP état américains ayant depuis l'arrêt
de la Cour suprême interdit l'IVG même
en cas de viol ou d'inceste je leur
rappelle aussi l'exemple de nos voisins
européens comme la Pologne où désormais
seuls les IVG en cas de viol ou de
danger pour la vie de la mè sont
autorisées la Hongrie qui oblige
maintenant les femmes souhaitant avorter
à écouter battre le cœur du fétus ou
même le Portugal qui impose aux femmes
depuis peu un examen psychologique
préalable personne ici ne saurait alors
préjuger de ce qu'il pourrait advenir
demain en France méfions-nous d'ailleurs
soyons vigilants car partout sur le
territoire les entrave à l'IVG prennent
des formes de plus en plus pernicieuses
de la part des mouvements antichoix
cherchant à tromper les femmes qui sont
peu ou mal informées afin qu'elles
poursuivent leur grossesse ils sont
nombreux y compris ici et très organisé
nous devons aussi convaincre ceux qui
pensent que la Constitution n'est pas un
catalogue de droit et que le droit à
l'avortement n'y aurait pas sa place à
cela nous leur demandons la Constitution
n'est-elle pas la norme suprême qui
permet à la nation d'indiquer les
valeurs et les principes auquels elle
donne une importance particulière et oui
la Constitution la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen le
préambule de la Constitution de 1946
font plus que fixer l'organisation
institué institutionnelle de notre pays
il rappelle les droits fondamentaux les
valeurs intangibles et tout ce qui fait
la force d'une République indivisible
laïque démocratique et social en ce sens
la constitutionnalisation des droits
reproductifs se justifie pleinement en
ce qu'elle permet de consacrer à la fois
l'égalité des citoyens et des citoyennes
ainsi a que l'effectivité de leurs
droits la Constitution c'est quelle
scène nous le rappelle la loi des lois
elle doit protéger ce qu'une loi simple
pourrait défaire demain enfin à ceux qui
estiment que ce droit serait déjà
protégé par le juge constitutionnel et
le juge européen à cela nous répondons
que le droit à l'avortement ne bénéficie
pas aujourd'hui de la protection
juridique la plus forte non il n'a
jamais été consacré par le juge
constitutionnel sur la d'un droit
fondamental non il ne jouit pas d'une
protection constitutionnelle autonome et
non il n'est pas protégé au niveau
européen en l'absence de consensus sur
la
question nous ne parlerons pas de ceux
qui pour des raisons purement politiques
ou politiciennes voudrait faire échouer
ce projet à cela nous n'avons pas de
réponse si ce n'est celle de la
responsabilité et du sens de notre
mandat nous leur disons tout simplement
au moment du vote pensez aux citoyennes
qui comptent sur nous
en 1975 l'opposition de gauche avait
choisi la conviction plutôt que la
posture et la dignité plutôt que le
calcul pour faire adopter la loi veille
refusée jusque dans son propre camp
alors nous leur disons comme nous
répondz à la grande
histoire certes la consécration du droit
à l'IVG pourrait être plus forte encore
avec une écriture plus ambitieuse nous
aurions en effet préféré la consécration
d'un droit plutôt que celle d'une
liberté afin de garantir un véritable
droit fondamental à l'IVG sans qu'il
soit nécessairement rattaché à la
liberté personnelle nous n'aurions pas
introduit l'IVG à l'article 34 mais nous
naurions plutôt consacré ce droit de
façon autonome en l'inscrivant à
l'article 1er qui est pour nous
lescrains des droits nous aurions
également voulu que la notion de
contraception y figure également mais
nous savons que les victoires féministes
ont toujours été le fruit du compromis
dès lors que l'on ne peut que l'on peut
obtenir l'essentiel sans ces compromis
qui refusent la compromission Simone
veille ne serait pas parvenu à faire
adopter la loi sur l'avortement
50 ans plus tard nous continuons donc à
adopter cette ligne constructive pour
faire primer l'intérêt des femmes
néanmoins monsieur le ministre nous
tenons toutefois à insister sur deux
points tout d'abord sur la notion
indispensable de garantie en effet de
l'avis des constitutionnalistes que nous
avons auditionné l'absence du mot
garantie créerait une incertitude sur la
volonté du constituant à se limiter au
rappel du droit existant ou pire à donné
au législateur une plus grande marge
d'appréciation qu'il s'agisse de faire
progresser ou reculer cette liberté
deuxièmement sur la mention du terme
femme cette rédaction ne doit pas être
interprétée comme excluante vis-à-vis
des personnes transjard par exemple le
Conseil d'État le rappelle d'ailleurs en
citant qu'il résulte de l'objet même de
cette liberté qu'elle doit bénéficier à
toutes les personnes ayant débuté une
grossesse sans
considérantation tenante à l'état civil
l'âge ou la nationalité et nous y tenons
c'est dans cet esprit que nous
proposerons un amendement reprenant la
proposition de loi de Cécile Hunter
meilleur et de notre groupe à savoir
l'inscription à l'article 1er de la
Constitution de la loi garanti
l'effectivité légale accès au droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
ainsi qu'à la contraception la mention
de l'effectivité de l'égal accès au
droit à l'avortement nous semble en
effet plus pertinente notamment quand on
sait que l'actuel ministre de la Santé
avait en 2017 saisi le Conseil
constitutionnel contre une loi venant
protéger
l'IVG n'oublions pas qu'encore
aujourd'hui ce sont au moins 3000 femmes
qui qui se voient contraintes d'avorter
à l'étranger mais parce que nous savons
que cette rédaction est le résultat d'un
compromis qui doit nous amener jusqu'au
congrès parce qu'il est important de
mettre rement en échec ceux qui
combattent les droits des femmes parce
qu'il est important d'avancer
collectivement sur les protections et
les garanties parce que des millions de
femmes d'aujourd'hui et de demain
attendent un signal fort et des droits
solides parce que partout dans le monde
la voie tracé par la France et regardé
et suivie quand il s'agit de protéger
des droits fondamentaux que beaucoup
trop de femmes n'ont pas et finalement
parce que c'est tout simplement juste et
nécessaire les socialistes voterons donc
avec fierté ce ce projet de loi
constitutionnel pour contribuer à faire
de ce jour une
victoire merci beaucoup ma cher
collègue la parole est à présent à
Madame Anne Cécile violent pour le
groupe
[Applaudissements]
horizon
madame la
présidente madame la ministre de
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
et la lutte contre les
discriminations monsieur le garde des
saau monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur chers
collègues pouvoir que le citoyen a de
faire ce qu'il veut sous la protection
des lois et dans les limite de
celle-ci c'est la définition de la
liberté pouvoir que le citoyen a de
faire ce qu'il veut sous la protection
des lois et dans les limites de
celles-ci permettez-moi monsieur le
garde des saau de partager votre fierté
et de vous remercier de votre engagement
assumé et
inspirant ce projet de loi
constitutionnel qui nous est soumis
aujourd'hui est un projet de loi qui
consacre la liberté de la femme la
protection de ses
choix et le rôle des représentants du
peuple dans la fixation du cadre dans
lesquels cette liberté s'exerce à
l'heure où nous débattons souvent
peut-être trop souvent de la mise en
place d'interdiction de sanctions de
normes contraignantes je me réjouis
aujourd'hui de prendre la parole devant
vous pour débattre de la
constitutionnalisation d'une
liberté la liberté de recourir à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
dont disposent les femmes franç 16
aujourd'hui cette liberté n'est pas
forth heureusement remise en cause ou
que très marginalement des récentes
manifestations bien que concentré et
minoritair porte une voix qu'il qualifie
de provie et nous rappelle que
malheureusement la liberté même de
recourir à l'IVG ne fait pas encore
totalement
consensus d'autres sans renier la
liberté de la femme estiment que l'IVG
n'a pas sa place dans la
Constitution je leur réponds en en me
permettant de reprendre à mon compte la
vie limpide du Conseil d'État je le
cite le caractère réversible et limité
de la protection conféré par la loi
ordinaire justifie que soit garantie par
la Constitution la liberté de la femme
de recourir à l'interruption volontaire
de
grossesse soyons honnêtes
c'est bien parce que cette liberté n'est
pas structurellement menacée aujourd'hui
que nous pouvons avoir ce débat et je
l'espère de manière
apaisé si un jour cette liberté était
menacée vous le savez comme moi il sera
trop
tard anticiper les risques c'est bâtir
un rempart avant
l'assaut ne pas attendre la catastrophe
pour se
préminir voilà la sagesse de l'assurance
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas
fini à ceux qui s'inquiètent de la
création d'un éventuel déséquilibre
entre deux principes à valeur
constitutionnelle que sont la liberté de
la femme et la sauvegarde de la dignité
de la personne humaine contre toute
forme de dégradation là encore je
réponds que ce n'est nullement
l'intention de ce projet de loi ce
projet de loi a un seul but encadrer
l'office de législateur afin qu'il ne
puisse interdire tout recours à l'IVG ni
en restreindre les conditions d'exercice
de façon tel qu'il pr qu'il priverait
cette liberté de toute
portée cette
constitutionnalisation c'est une
assurance pour les femmes françaises que
nul ne pourra remettre en cause c'est
leur liberté de choisir cette liberté
est bien trop importante structurante et
je dirais même essentielle pour que nous
baissions la la garde et ne fassions pas
preuve d'une grande vigilance comme nous
y invitait Simone de
beauauvoir cette vigilance s'accroit
lorsque l'on voit coutre Atlantique la
Cour suprême a mis un terme à sa célèbre
jurisprudence Ry versus Wade de
1973 ce que l'on pensait acquis dans nos
sociétés modernes ne l'est jamais
définitivement surtout lorsque l'on
parle de droits des
femmes cette vigilance s'acroit encore
davantage lorsque l'on voit qu'au sein
même de certains pays de l'Union
européenne ce droit est considérablement
restreint aux exemples du Portugal de la
Hongrie de la Pologne déjà évoqué je
vais vous parler de Malte Malte jusqu'au
28 juin de l'année
2023 l'IVG était strictement interdite
passible d'une peine de 18 mois à 3 ans
pour les femmes
strictement interdite pour les femmes
pardon et passible d'une peine de 18
mois à 3 ans pour les médecins qui la
pratiquent 4 ans de prison et
interdiction
d'exercer la seule exception aujourd'hui
qui a été votée le 28
juin c'est quand le fetus est non viable
et que la vie de la mère est en
danger à ceux qui pensent que le droit
de l'avortement n'est pas menacé en
France je leur pose la question suivante
avez-vous besoin de davantage d'exemples
combien de pays doivent restreindre ce
droit avant d'admettre la nécessité de
le
protéger avons-nous besoin d'attendre
face à ses retours en arrière la France
doit montrer l'exemple consacrer cette
liberté au sommet de la hiérarchie des
normes de notre ferait de notre pays oui
le premier pays au monde et le premier
pays à protéger au sein de sa
constitution la santé physique mais
aussi la santé psychique des femmes
contre les risques que présente un
avortement dans la
clandestinité en héritier de Simone
veille nous nous prémunirions ainsi
contre la possibilité d'un retour au
faiseuses
d'ange près de 50 ans après la loi
fondatrice du 17 janvier
1975 en empêchant la remise en cause par
la loi de la liberté d'avoir recours à
l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse c'est un message fort envoyé
aux hommes et aux femmes de ce monde
entier
mesdames votre liberté de choisir fait
partie intégrante des valeurs
fondamentales de notre pays votre corps
n'est pas un territoire à réguler mais
plutôt un espace sacré de libre arbitre
et
d'autodétermination parce qu'il y a une
réalité qui rend cette liberté si
fragile elle ne fait aujourd'hui l'objet
d'aucune consécration en tant que telle
et encore une fois c'est le Conseil
d'État qui le rappelle dans nos textes
fondateurs notre Constitution la
Convention européenne de sauvegarde des
droits de l'homme et des libertés
fondamentales ou encore le droit de
l'Union européenne si le Conseil
constitutionnel dans sa décision du 27
juin 2001 a fait le choix d'adosser la
valeur constitutionnelle de la liberté
de la femme de recourir à l'IVG à celle
de la liberté de la femme prévue par
l'article 2 de la Déclaration des Droits
de l'Homme et du Citoyen le temps est
venu de lui consacrer une valeur tionn
autonome non non la Constitution n'est
pas un catalogue de droits sociaux la
Constitution c'est l'esprit d'un peuple
d'une époque d'une volonté c'est
Jean-Louis Debray 14 octobre 2018 qu'il
exprimait à l'occasion du 60e
anniversaire de la
Constitution je me réjouis en outre que
la rédaction proposé aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement soit le fruit du long
travail mené par l'ensemble des
parlementaires à la assemblée à à
l'initiative des présidentes Panau
hébergé nous avions adopté une
proposition qui a été retravaillée par
nos collèges sénateurs et je salue la
sénatrice Vogel des divergences étaient
alors apparues quant à l'endroit où il
fallait placer ce texte au sein de la
Constitution sur la question sémantique
de savoir s'il fallait consacrer un
droit ou une liberté sur le choix des
mots pour s'assurer de lui donner sa
pleine force mais à l'Assemblée comme au
Sénat ces propositions de loi
constitutionnell ont été adoptées preuve
qu'il existe une voie de passage et en
tout é cas de cause un consensus de
constitutionnalisation je salue aussi
les association féministe pour leur
composition
constructive ainsi les rédactions
adoptées ont été retravaillées par le
gouvernement et enrichi des remarques
pertinentes soulevées par le Conseil
d'État la rédaction de compromis qui
nous est soumise aujourd'hui emporte
ainsi notre approbation car elle précise
que c'est à la loi de garantir
l'effectivité et l'accès à l'IVG en
d'autres termes qu'il revient aux
représentants du peuple de déterminer
les conditions dans lesquelles ce droit
est exercé ainsi la liberté de recourir
à l'IVG sera protégée de façon pérenne
tout en continuant à être encadré par un
processus démocratique d'autre part
l'emploi d'une formule positive permet
d'assurer la constitutionnalité d'un
d'un certain nombre de dispositifs
importants dans notre droit et notamment
la clause des médecins la clause de
conscience des médecins et des
sages-femmes
résolument attaché à la liberté de
choisir notre groupe horizon et
apparenté sera toujours guidé par la
volonté d'empêcher une quelconque remise
en cause de l'équilibre défini par la
loi veille et l'assurance solennelle que
rien ne pourra entraver ou défaire ce
qui sera ainsi irréversible nous
voterons donc en faveur de ce projet de
loi dans sa rédaction actuelle je vous
remercie je vous remercie ma cher
collègue
la parole est à Madame Sandra regol pour
le groupe écologiste pour une durée de 5
minutes merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre monsieur
le ministre le président le rapporteur
mes chers collègues ça fait bientôt 50
ans depuis la loi veille 50 ans que
malgré l'acquisition d'un droit les
femmes continue à se justifier se sent
en devoir de se justifier alors qu'elle
dispose de ce droit à recourir à l'IVG
sans qu'Ant que n'en déplaise à ceux qui
disent que rien n'est en danger la
justification permanente rappelle que
non rien n'est gagné rien n'est acquis
les manifestations contre nos droits les
agressions à proximité des centres les
attaques contre le planning familial
récurrente tout ceci nous rappelle
cruellement que malgré le droit rien
n'est jamais acquis pourtant le droit à
l'IVG est une conquête féministe
j'insiste sur ce mot qui instaure le
droit des femmes en en France le droit à
disposer de leur corps et par conséquent
de leur vie ce n'est pas un combat
récent il a été mené par nos aînés
c'estes féministes vous savez qui
étaaiit vilipandé parce que leur mot
étaient trop haut le Verbe était trop
fort ces avorteuses ces fauseuses d'ange
qui étaient poursuivi par la justice et
dont l'histoire aujourd'hui célèbre
l'apport parce qu'en réalité ce sont des
vies entières qu'elles ont sauvé ces
femmes qui nétaaiit rien mais qui
ensemble faisaient front faisait en
sorte que leur sororité puisse nous per
d'être là aujourd'hui merci donc à elles
qui ont tracé ce
sillon merci à celles qui reprennent le
flambeau aujourd'hui et je sais qu'elles
sont nombreuses dans ces travers et dans
ces balcons
elles ont tracé le son donc ces femmes
qui nous conduitent à délibérer
aujourd'hui sur ce texte qui constiue
une fuite à leur travail une fuite mais
certainement pas en point final
malheureusement pas en point final il
n'est qu'une étape dans ce long
processus qui est celui de notre
empouvoir main autrement dit celui de
l'égalité en tout temps nos doits
peuvent être mis en danger dès lors
qu'ils ne sont pas institué on pense
naturellement aux États-Unis et à la
Pologne nos collègues en ont parlé à
tous ces pays où en réalité c'est la
bascule politique qui produit une
fracture dans le socle fondamental de
nos droits et dans ces cas-là ce sont
toujours les femmes qui sont les
premières victimes car sont bien des
bascules politiques conjoncturelles qui
défondent les libertés qui pourtant a
été durement acquise mais c'est aussi
une réalité française avec évidemment
ces sites qui incitent les femmes à
culpabiliser à renoncer à leurs droits
c'est déserts médicaux qui rendent
l'accès à l'IVG inégalitaire sur le
territoire et certains médecins qui
refusent de pratiquer ses interventions
ou culpabilise les femmes parce que oui
on l'a toute connu directement ou
indirectement cette honte qu'on qu'on ne
ressentait pas mais que certains se
sentent le droit de nous nous donner par
nos proches par nos familles autour de
nous cette honte là elle doit changer de
camp ces bascules représentent un point
commun donc la politique celle des
réactionnaires toujours toujours prêt à
empêcher les femmes à disposer de leur
corps et de leur vie à les empêcher de
décider de leur avenir à les rendre
dépendantes ici même dans nos rangs et à
ma droite encore une fois nous avons dû
subir ces discours qui font toujours
passer les femmes au dernier plan et qui
renit incessamment nos droits certains
d'ailleurs et pas qu'à ma droite
persistent à légiférer sur le ventre des
femmes en nous faisant une mauvaise
reprise de la servante écarlate pour
nous obliger à produire selon des quotas
ce sont les mêmes qui opposent les
droits des femmes à ceux d'un féus qui
refusent de construire l'histoire parce
que c'est la nôtre celle des femmes à
nos collègues qui s'inquiètent des
conséquences possibles qui le font
sincèrement je le redis
constitutionnaliser ce n'est pas
banaliser c'est sanctuariser un droit
celui des femmes ce n'est pas
démultiplier les recours à l'IVG ce
n'est pas nier le choix de celles qui ne
veulent pas y recourir c'est s'assurer
que quoi qu'il arrive le droit n'ira pas
à rebours que nos droits ne régressent
pas mais c'est aussi inscrire la France
dans l'Histoire celle du premier pays à
agir en faveur d'une constitution alors
certes nous préférions ce travail mené
par des femmes madame Panau madame Vogel
madame
berger parce qu'elles étaient capables
de travailler ensemble et je crois que
sans elles nous n'aurions pas ce texte
aujourd'hui certes nous préférions la
formulation de notre collègue Mathilde
Panau qui permettait de garantir l'accès
à l'IVG et incluer la
contraception nous défendrons des
amendements qui vont dans ce sens
pourtant il y a un seul objectif qui
surçoit tout autre enjeu construire
notre histoire constitutionnaliser fûce
seulement l'article 34
constitutionnalisé fus dans une version
revue à la baisse cette liberté publique
fondamentale de toutes les femmes alors
en conclusion comme le rappelle l'hyne
des femmes c'est debout que nous avons
avancé c'est debout que nous avancerons
et ne ratons pas ce rendez-vous avec
l'Histoire constitutionnons l'IVG et
continuons ce combat ensemble merci
beaucoup ma cher
collègu la parole est à Madame Elsa
fossillon pour le groupe Gauche
démocrate et
républicaine
ci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur chers collègues ce projet
de loi de
constitutionnalisation du droit à
l'avortement et bien c'est un le fruit
de longues luttes féministes de luttes
qui devront évidemment se poursuivre je
veux dire pour commencer que c'est un
honneur aujourd'hui de prononcer cette
intervention pour mon groupe en faveur
de cette
constitutionnalisation j'ai une pensée
pour toutes les femmes qui dans les
collectifs les associations ont mené
cette lutte acharnée qui nous mène ici
aujourd'hui
j'adresse aussi mes remerciements
amicaux aux parlementaires qui ont Terai
apporter cette revendication entre les
murs de cette assemblée je pense
notamment à Mathilde Panau à Albane
Gaillot à Marie Noël btisten à erouan
balanan à Marie-Charlotte Garin ou
encore à Mélanie Vaugel ou Guillaume
Gouffier Vallante enfin en ce jour je
veux envoyer toute ma solidarité mon
soutien aux femmes qui défendent ce
droit à travers le monde et qui
subissent à cause de cela harcèlement
stigmatisation violence physique et
procès cette loi je le crois n'est pas
veine ou cosmétique elle est
profondément politique car nos corps
sont politiques et le corps des femmes
en particulier tant ils sont sont scruté
réglementé avec un pouvoir de contrôle
cette loi elle est donc politique et
utile à l'heure notamment de la montée
en puissance de fascisme à l'URE
européenne à l'échelle européenne c'est
un droit bafoué dans de nombreux pays
mais également chez nos voisins
européens d'autres l'ont dit la Pologne
a adopté une interdiction quasi totale
de l'avortement en octobre 2021 la
Hongrie propose quant-elle une loi qui
obligera les femmes à écouter les
battements de cœur de leur fus avant de
subir une interruption de grossesse en
matière de droit des femmes l'extrême
droite a une constante celle de
combattre et de mépriser toutes celles
qui défendent ses droits il n'y a pas si
longtemps Marine Le Pen parlait encore
d'IVG de confort n'hésitant pas à dire
écoutez bien je refuse que des femmes se
fassent avorter à plusieurs reprises
quand d'autres au même moment doivent
renoncer aux soins faute de moyens à
l'Assemblée nationale comme au Parlement
européen les élus de son parti se sont
opposés quasiment unanimement et
systématiquement aux textes qui
promeuvent l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes que ce soit pour l'égalité
salariale l'accès à la contraception la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes et les violences de genre ou la
promotion de la parité Éric Zemour a
fait du combat contre le féminisme un
combat contre la dévirilisation de
l'Occident et contre le grand
remplacement l'extrême droite est bien
un danger pour les droits des femmes
aussi à ceux qui souhaitent aussi à ceux
qui souhaitent classer le droit à l'IVG
au de droit sociétal nous leur répondons
que la liberté a disposer de son corps
et les droits sexuels et reproductifs
sont des droits fondamentaux à part
entière et ont à ce titre toute leur
place dans la
Constitution le droit à disposer de son
corps est un droit fondamental et
essentiel à la liberté individuelle il
est donc une condition indispensable à
l'existence de toutes les autres
libertés c'est aussi je le crois une
manière de se prémunir de ces politiques
natalistes qui font du ventre des fables
des femmes une variable d'ajustement
démographique au mépris de ses droits
fondamentaux il faut le rappeler le
droit à avorter c'est une question de
vie ou de mort selon le MS encore 47000
femmes par an dans le monde meurent d'un
avortement clandestin soit une femme
toutes les 9 minutes mes chers collègues
messieurs les femmes qui veulent avorter
avortent c'est le cas depuis la nuit des
temps et lorsqu'elles n'ont pas ce droit
elles trouvent tous les moyens possibles
pour mettre fin à cette grossesse
quitent à mettre leur propre vie en
périle en s'enfonçant une aiguille de
l'eau saveneuse ou persile dans l'utérus
en se mutilant le ventre en ingérant de
l'acide ce projet de loi est donc
attendu de longu dates à la fois par les
associations mais aussi par celles et
ceux qui souhaitent s'assurer de la
protection absolue de ce droit notamment
depuis l'arrêt depuis l'annulation de
l'arrêt R contre W par la Cour suprême
américaine qui a eu une résonance
internationale dans certains pays tels
que le Kenya le Nigeria l'Éthiopie ou
l'Inde des mouvements anti-avortement
ont saisi cette opportunité pour
parvenir à l'arrêt de processus
législatif progressiste en faveur des
droits sexuels et reproductifs en fait
les régressions comme les conquêtes ont
une résonance mondiale en France ce
séisme outreAtlantique a réouvert le
débat autour de la
constitutionnalisation du droit à l'IVG
je veux rappeler que selon un sondage
pour la Fondation des femmes et le
planning familial de février 2021 93 %
des Français se disent attachés au droit
à l'avortement et que selon un sondage
de la Fondation Jean jorè 81 % des
Français sont favorables à la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG pourtant
cela ne nuit pas à la vigueur des
associations anti-avortement abreuvé de
financement opaque selon un rapport de
2021 du forum parlementaire européen
pour les droits sexuels Act et
reproductif entre 2009 et 2018 près de
707 millions de dollars ont été reversés
au mouvement anti-droits des femmes et
antiavortement en Europe la France fait
partie des cibles prioritaires de ces
mouvements ces associations se pai des
campagnes régulières et d'ampleur
manifestations antivg diffusion de
fausses informations auprès des femmes
sur Internet mobilisation des élus
conservateurs les antiivg redoublent
d'idées pour empêcher les femmes
d'avorter je pense notamment et vous
l'avez vu à la campagne coordonnée
d'autocollant à posé sur des vélos à
Paris en imitant parfaitement la charte
graphique des vélibes afin de créer le
doute chez les usagers les réseaux
sociaux sont également devenus un lieu
privilégié pour ces campagnes le jeune
public y est une cible de choix à titre
d'exemple selon un rapport de la
Fondation des femmes et de l'ISD en 2024
sur Instagram 1/5e des vidéos les plus
recommandées sur l'avortement sur
Instagram contiennent des fausses
informations des contenus promant
promouvant des styles de de vie
appelé femme au foyer et des contenus de
santé alternativ comme des fausses
informations sur la pilule cont
contraceptif par exemple je vous le dis
tel quel nous allons voter avec
détermination évidemment ce texte même
si nous pensons que la rédaction
actuelle est améliorable nous regrett en
premier lieu l'absence de mention du
droit à la contraception tant nous
savons qu'il va de paire avec ce droit à
l'avortement dans le monde 225 millions
de femmes qui souhaiteraient différer ou
éviter une grossesse n'ont pas accès à
une contraception sûre et efficace et on
sait que c'est également une arme de
choix des antivg pour s'attaquer au
ventre des femmes la présence du terme
garantir va dans le bon sens cela
sous-entend je le crois que l'État doit
mettre en œuvre les mesures nécessaires
pour la bonne application de ce droit
néanmoins en l'état actuel de la
rédaction si le droit à l'IVG ne peut
être supprimé des conditions peuvent
être ajouté pour le meilleur comme pour
le pire c'est ainsi que nous avons
proposé par voie d'amendement la
formulation retenue lors du travail
parlementaire transpartisan mené à
l'Assemblée nationale par ailleurs
disons-le le droit à l'IVG est également
en danger à cause des restrictions de
personnel dans les hôpitaux publics et
des suppressions de centres d'orthogénie
130 centres IVG ont été fermés C 15
dernières années et d'autres sont
menacés les personnes en situation de
pauvreté de migration d'exclusion et les
personnes mineures en sont les premières
victimes oui il y a bien une question de
classe madame berger sur cette question
et lors du procès de bobini Giselle
Alimi nous avertissait ainsi c'est
toujours la même classe celle des femmes
pauvres vulnérables économiquement et
socialement cette classe des sans argent
et des sans relation qui est frappé le
droit à l'IVG existe aujourd'hui mais le
manque de moyens on fait un droit moins
accessible pour les plus précaires nous
l'avons constaté pendant la crise du
covid mais cela perdure les associations
l'affirme dans certains territoires
certaines semaines il n'y a aucune
opportunité de faire des avortements
soit du fait de la démographie des
professionnels soit durant les périodes
estivales il apparaît donc que la
constitutionnalisation du droit à l'IVG
nous oblige et vous oblige à prendre en
compte une nécessaire mise de moyens je
veux pour finir m'adresser aux collègues
du Sénat ici à l'Assemblée nous avons
d'abord procédé avec un travail
transpartisan qui a amené chacun et
chacune à des compromis puis aujourd'hui
après le travail du Sénat nous faisons
de nouveau compromis pour permettre la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG je veux
donc dire et rappeler au conseil aux
sénateurs et sénatrices que aussi doit
faire preuve et œuvre de compromis pour
que nous y
arrivions vous l'aurez compris nous
pensons que ce texte est perfectible et
nous savons que en matière de droits des
femmes et de conquête et bien il y a
toujours beaucoup de lutte à mener mais
mes chers collègues j'espère vraiment
que très vite nous pourrons dédier cette
conquête historique à toutes celles qui
se sont battu et se battent encore à
travers le monde pour le droit à l'IVG
et à la contraception je vous remercie
merci beaucoup mon chers
collègu la parole est à Madame
Marie-Charlotte Garin pour le groupe
écologiste
madame la présidente madame la ministre
messieur le ministre le président de
commission et le
rapporteur un million de femmes se font
avorter chaque année en France elles le
font dans des conditions dangereuses en
raison de la clandestinité à laquelle
elles sont condamnées alors que cette
opération pratiqué sous contrôle médical
est des plus simples on fait le silence
sur ces millions de femmes
je déclare que je suis l'une d'elles je
déclare avoir
avorté de même que nous réclamons le
libre accès au moyens
anticonceptionnel nous réclamons
l'avortement
libre ces mots datent de
1971 alors que le Manifeste des 343
personnalités célèbres ou anonymes
appelle à la légalisation de
l'avortement en
France nous sommes collectivement les
héritiers et les héritières de celles
qui nous ont précédé pour avoir le droit
d'avorter dans de bonnes
conditions je veux d'abord commencer par
dire MERCI MERCI Simone merci Giselle
merci Monique merci Delphine Christiane
merci au mouvement de libération des
femmes merci au mouvement pour la
liberté de l'avortement et de la
contraception merci à toutes les
associations pour leur travail merci à
toutes les femmes politiques qui en ont
été
l'écho merci à toutes celles et ceux qui
ont œuvré inlassablement pour sauver la
vie des femmes qui ont eu besoin de
l'avortement c'est l'Histoire avec un
grand H celle qui s'écrit au féminin
dans le contrefort des grands discours
cette mobilisation de milliers de femmes
qui dans l'illégalité ont permis aux
autres femmes d'avorter qui ont tenu la
main des plus jeunes calmer les
angoisses apportter des réponses répondu
à la détresse pris des risques pour que
celle qui ne voulaient pas celle qui ne
pouvait pas puisse choisir librement
dans une société qui les en empêchait si
elle voulaaient ou non avoir un enfant
parce que la pilune n'a pas marché parce
que le préservatif a craqué parce qu'on
a oublié parce que la vie est trop chère
trop dure pour construire une famille
parce que le corps ne peut pas parce que
le cœur ne veut pas parce que toujours
cela doit rester un
choix que celles qui veulent avorter le
peuvent que celles qui ne le veulent pas
s'en abstienne et que tous ceux qui
disent vouloir défendre la vie
permettent massivement l'accès à la
contraception à l'éducation à la vie
sexuelle etve et affective qu'ils
permettent l'implication à égalité des
deux parents qu'ils accompagnent les
familles soutiennent des politiques plus
justes pour les plus précaires et les
famille monoparental puisque ce sont
souvent des femmes qu'il financent le
planning familial et toutes les
associations de terrain qui se battent
pour la santé des femmes qu'ils agissent
enfin pour nous garantir un accès à
l'IVG et à la santé sexuelle et
reproductive sur tout le TER
sans
exception on ne n'est pas
femme mais on peut en mourir quand on n'
pas accès à des soins de qualité près de
chez soi rendre plus difficile l'accès à
l'avortement pour les femmes ça n'est
pas faire diminuer le nombre
d'avortements dans ce pays c'est faire
augmenter le nombre de femmes qui en
meurent aujourd'hui parce que la loi a
changé hier ne pas mourir quand on
avorte c'est la réalité d'Alice de
Mathilde de Samia de de Christel de nos
mères de nos sœurs de vos filles et de
tant d'autres anonymes qui ne nous
doivent rien ni à nous ni à personne pas
une explication pas une excuse
puisqu'elles ont un droit celui de
choisir celui de dire non au réarmement
démographique non aux politiques
natalistes qui instrumentalisent nos
corps et ébranlent nos
libertés notre pays ne peut pas se
ranger au côté des États-Unis de Trump
ou de la Hongrie de
Orban il nous faut être responsable et
construire des digues pour protéger nos
droits fondamentaux face à la montée de
la boue fasciste partout en
Europe les corbeaux sont à nos portes et
nous ne leur laisserons pas nos
corps inscrire le droit à l'IVG dans la
Constitution c'est dire à nos petites
sœurs que si notre vie durant il faut se
battre pour nos droits plus jamais elle
ne devront se battre pour celui-là plus
jamais plus jamais inquiété plus plus
jamais condamné plus jamais les cintes
plus jamais la peur plus jamais la mort
toujours la liberté le droit à disposer
de son corps toujours le choix le choix
le choix d'être maire ou
pas merci beaucoup ma ch
collègu et pour terminer cette
discussion générale
madame CR pour une durée de 5
minutes madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre mesdames
et messieurs les députés chers
collègues en me tenant devant vous
aujourd'hui je suis consciente de la
gravité du sujet qui nous occupe nous
sommes ici pour discuter non pas de
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
en tant que telle mais de sa place dans
notre Constitution le sanctuaire
national qui est le fondement même de
nos valeurs et de notre identité en tant
que peuple français précisons les choses
car argenttin déjà les tenants de la
pensée unique nous expliquer ici et là
que ceux qui s'opposent au texte qui
nous est soumis sont contre l'IVG c'est
faux et je vais m'en expliquer cette
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
visant à graver dans le marbre le droit
à l'avortement soullève au combien la
question de sa
nécessité permettez-moi de m'interroger
quelle est l'utilité d'inscrire dans
notre Constitution un droit qui n'a
jamais été sérieusement contesté au sein
de notre pays à quoi tout cela rime-t-il
est-ce là le meilleur usage de notre
temps législatif alors que d'autres
sujets de société urgent et criant
attendent notre action sommes-nous
conscients que nous concentrons notre
énergie pour sacraliser un droit qui n'a
jamais été réellement menacé non le
droit à l'avortement n'est pas remise en
cause mais il y a par contre un vrai
sujet chers collègues dont nous devrions
nous saisir c'est celui de
l'accompagnement des femmes qui font
face au drame de l'avortement en effet
s'il y a bien une chose à faire c'est de
de soutenir le mieux possible les femmes
qui ont eu recours à cet acte de
détresse avorter n'est pas anodin tous
les témoignages le confirme si l'IVG est
un droit cela reste une blessure morale
par ailleurs je trouve que c'est assez
désolant de vouloir copier aveuglément
les États-Unis pensant que tout ce qui
est bon pour eux est aussi pour nous la
France doiton le rappeler à sa propre
histoire sa propre identité desquelles
doivent découler des solutions uniques
et pas automatiques cette loi est
inutile et n'est qu'un écran de fumée
destiné à occulter des problèmes bien
plus pressents les Français nous
attendent sur d'autres sujets notre pays
est confronté à des défis majeurs un
système éducatif en péril un hôpital
public à bout de souffle une insécurité
qui nous ronge le traitement souvent
négligé de nos aînés des agriculteurs et
des pêcheurs en colère et cetera et
cetera et pourtant aujourd'hui nous
regardons
ailleurs la politique dans son naissance
la plus noble c'est aussi je je crois
l'art de prioriser les problèmes les
plus criants de notre société et d'y
apporter des réponses empreintes de
justice et d'audace il y a quelques
jours par exemple le président de la
République nous partageait une grande
tirade sur le problème de la démographie
française et au même moment il veut
sacraliser l'avortement n'est-ce pas là
tout le paradoxe du en même temps trois
constats s'imposent une dénatalité sans
précédent depuis la dernière guerre un
triste record avec plus de 230000
avortements 2022 et une politique
familiale inexistante depuis François
Hollande nous devons donc nous
interroger sur le fait que de plus en
plus de femmes avortent alors qu'elles
sont de moins en moins nombreuses à
accoucher alors plutôt que de légiférer
sur des lois inutiles ne serait-il pas
plus salutaire d'envisager enfin grand
plan Marchal pour encourager les
naissances et la célébration de la vie
transmettons aux futures générations
l'idéal de la vie pas celui de la mort
faisons renaître en eux un nouvel espoir
l'espoir que leurs enfants pourront
grandir et s'épanouir dans une France
sûre et résolument tourné vers un avenir
plus prometteur s'il vous plaît mes
chers collègues quel est notre rôle quel
est notre devoir notre devoir en tant
que représentant du peuple français et
d'agir avec sagesse et prévoyance en
accordant la priorité aux enjeux qui
façonnent le quotidien et l'avenir de
nos concitoyens certainement pas en
accordant la priorité à des sujets déjà
résolus la Constitution de notre
République c'est elle qui décide des
valeurs fondamentales qui doivent régir
notre pays chaque modification que nous
y apportons doit être mûement réfléchi
pesé et empreinte de notre
responsabilité envers les générations
présentes et futures montesque ne
disait-il pas que nous devions toucher
la Constitution que d'une main
tremblante à défaut nous nous rendrions
coupables d'avoir ouvert la boîte de
Pandor alors en toute responsabilité et
convaincu que le socle de notre
République ne doit pas être VI coup de
la majorité je voterai contre cette
proposition de
loi je vous remercie madame la députée
la discussion générale est close